tucker carlson was right
tucker came out on the show and said
that he got information that the nsa had
been spying on him
that they wanted to leak information to
get them taken off the air the nsa
issued a non-denial denial what does
that mean
it means they put out a statement that
sort of seems like they're saying they
didn't do it but they didn't actually
deny anything
they basically said tucker's never been
a target and
we only target foreign people we all
knew what that meant because glenn
greenwald covered this he exposed them
edward stone and leaked the information
sure they can spy on a foreign
individual but if your communications
are somewhere in between
they can still get access plus their
bulk spying on the american people
anyway
well as it turns out now someone leaked
to a journalist at axios
who tucker carlson was talking to he was
apparently talking to people in the
kremlin inner circle
trying to get an interview with vladimir
putin if tucker carlson didn't preempt
this story
the narrative right now would be tucker
colluding with russians
i i would absolutely be willing to bet
that's the case
but because tucker came out and said
they're spying on our communications
working on a story
the narrative is tucker was trying to
interview putin
so there you go somebody leaked that
information how did they get it even if
they weren't spying on tucker
who gave them the right to unmask him
meaning when an american citizen gets
captured when their data gets captured
by the nsa
it's supposed to be hidden that means
somebody went to a fisa court
and a judge signed off on revealing a
u.s journalist's name
who was trying to interview a world
leader none of this adds up but i can
tell you what does
all of the morons in the mainstream
press who have so much egg on their face
you can make an omelette
because they were for days being like
tucker so dumb he's making it up
and now they're going this is really
interesting i wonder how this
information could have been leaked this
is something we should talk about
people are like yo you were just i'm
sick of these people so we're going to
get into this obviously i'm heated on
this
tucker was right ladies and gentlemen he
wasn't making it up
of course they're trying to come out and
save save their save face by saying
well we don't know for sure it was the
nsa that leaked this
i just asked jonathan swan to to publish
his sources and if the nsa was
committing illegal acts i don't think he
should defend those sources
but they want to unmatch tucker unmask
the source let's see what we got going
on
joining us today is the return of jack
murphy hello everybody i'm back
it is a wednesday and we are now back on
the every other wednesday schedule i'm
jack murphy
so happy to be here follow me on twitter
jack murphy live sub
on youtube jack murphy live tim great to
see you
you are heated before the show you're
heated now it's going to be hot tonight
i had a beer you're excited ian's here
i'm back with lids that's right all is
right in the world today wednesdays are
back jack murphy on time
wild wild animal i murphy in the house
i i'm disturbed about these secret
fights at courts oh right we're
supposed to yeah we're talking about
serious stuff i've been disturbed about
this fisa courts for like 15 years i
mean when it was the first time that it
was
it was elucidated to the public well the
first time i really heard about it was
michael cernovich breaking the fisa
unmasking with susan rice and mike flynn
case that is the first time i heard
about it mike way to go that was me
personally yeah yeah
uh that's how i came to understand how
the fisa courts work and what it means
to be revealed and unmasked if you've
been
sort of caught up in this snare of
foreign intelligence work and they're
snooping on people
this is just a journalist there's
there's a lot to this the five eye spy
club yeah what that means
how they how they how they cheat the
laws and violate rights we'll get into
all this as well
we'll get into all of this though we've
got lids just pressing all the time i'm
here in the corner as well
i'm very intrigued for tonight it's
going to be a lot of fun we haven't had
jack in a couple weeks
so it's going to be a great conversation
tucker was absolutely right and i knew
that he wouldn't have brought this up
without valid reason to do so
so of course he's correct and i'm
curious what all is behind that now
before we get started my friends we got
a great sponsor we got virtual shield
you know them you love them they are the
first sponsor that i've ever had
go to surfing internetsafe.com the link
is in the description below
and you can get a vpn virtual private
network service this is perfect you know
what vpns do
they help keep your data safe from
prying eyes from people who want to spy
on you
convenient if you go to
surfinginternetsafe.com they say you
will stay safe with fifty percent off
for life
just two dollars and fifty cents per
month
you know i try to explain vpns in a very
simple way usually i just say like
it's a basic level of security you lock
your doors and your windows you don't
expect anybody
anybody to break in but you still lock
up because you're not going to risk it
right that's what vpns provide for you
but just how perfect is it that we're
now learning about
one of the highest profile individuals
in politics
in the culture war having his
information intercepted
now look i'm going to be real with you i
don't think a vpn's going to protect you
from the nsa spying on vladimir putin
but it's another example of the dirty
tricks that you get from not just the
government from from hackers from
private corporations
they want to spy on data they want to
sell your data they want to learn things
about you some of these social media
companies have profiles on you and
you've never even signed up
virtual shield a virtual private network
service is one way to help keep that
data
safe it obfuscates it sends it through a
network encrypts it you can even make it
look like you're coming from a different
country
more importantly virtual shield's been a
sponsor of mine since i started doing
youtube that means a lot it really does
because there are a lot of companies
that are willing to cancel people fire
people
this is one of the companies doing the
exact opposite saying hey we want to
sponsor this show and be involved so go
to surfinginternetsafe.com
sign up with virtual shield get access
to that vpn protect your data
but don't forget go to timcast.com
become a member
we're gonna have a bonus segment coming
up later tonight this is usually where
we talk about the things that youtube
doesn't allow us to talk about
but more importantly we are hiring a ton
of journalists we're gonna have like six
or seven people on the news newsroom
staff
probably by probably by the end of the
month plus we've got the paranormal show
coming
with your membership we are building
culture
we are reporting news we're going to be
hiring fact checkers it's going to be
huge so
don't forget get that members-only
content over at timcast.com
and like this video subscribe to this
channel hit that notification bell which
apparently doesn't matter all that much
share share this podcast right now take
the url post it on facebook twitter
whatever just share it share it share it
that's that's the word of mouth if if
this is a story that you think is
important
you think our conversations are
important sharing is the best thing you
can do
and if you're listening on itunes or
spotify give us give us some five stars
if you really do like it let's
let's jump into this story here's the
big breaking news
it's a scoop so saith axios tucker
carlson sought putin interview at
time of spying claim that's that's it
right there
now for those who are not familiar with
the story let me just rehash real
quickly for those are just tuning in
tugger carlson came out on the show and
said someone revealed to him
information that was in his texts and
his emails that no one else had access
to
this long story short said to him the
nsa was spying on
on him and his communications this is
what was conveyed to him he said the
intent was to leak it
to get his show taken off the air as
soon as he comes out and says this
of course all the conservatives say i
trust tucker i don't think he's going to
make this up
not even just conservatives just you
know anti-establishment types and of
course the establishment immediately
said
he's making it up he's lying he's bsing
he's not being spied on and the nsa
themselves issued what's called a
non-denial denial
where they said tucker's claim that
we're trying to get his show taken off
the air is
untrue perhaps semantics
but they never outright denied that they
intercepted his communications
and tucker said he pressed them so or
him or one of his staff said
are you reading our emails and they
refuse to issue a response
all of a sudden a story comes out that
tucker was going to try and interview
vladimir putin
which means the story did get leaked
from who
i'd have to imagine tucker was right it
was the nsa jonathan swann of axios can
just reveal who his sources
he says tucker carlson was talking to
us-based kremlin intermediaries about
setting up an interview with vladimir
putin
shortly before the fox news host accused
the nsa of spying on him
sources familiar with the conversations
telexios
now how are they familiar with those
conversations if tucker says he didn't
share them with anybody
is the source actually someone at fox
news who's stabbed tucker in the back
no the person that tucker claims unless
unless okay of course you can still say
tucker's a liar
but tucker preempted this think about
what would have happened if tucker never
said anything
the story right now would be leaked
communications show tucker trying to
negotiate deals with vladimir putin or
something to that effect
instead because tucker came out and said
he was working on a story
the narrative is now while tucker was
claiming to be working on a story
he was talking to people who are kremlin
intermediaries
i think he he he ripped the fangs out i
think he calmed this one down it was a
smart move
and they dragged him over it now the
funny thing is all these journalists
that are trying to act like it's oh oh
i'm a serious reporter oh this
it must be true even though they were
the ones dragging him the whole time
that's what you can expect man right
man i'm a journalist my number one job
is to go to the source my number one job
is to get the best interview possible
who would be a better interviewee than a
leader of one
of the un security council members
the leader of their country vladimir
putin i'm interested to to examine a
little bit more deeply the timing of
this it says here that they were talking
to putin now it's about him trying to
get an interview with putin now
yep so this is in real time this isn't
this isn't even uh
trump is in office this isn't even
during trump
russia scandal or whatnot this is just
tucker carlson going about his normal
business as a journalist who interviews
top leading world officials
and they snared him in their
international spy ring that's
coordinated against
multiple or coordinated with multiple
different english-speaking countries
five eyes right
and they they were like hey we need to
figure out who this guy is so they took
him to a fiesta court they made a case
right they had to make a case to a
special judge
to say this is why we should be able to
figure out who this american citizen
is and what could the case have been
this guy wants to talk to putin oh
he must be a spy if it's the nsa and
i don't think tucker is lying on this
one we've got his claim the story gets
leaked
it makes sense it's not like the nsa
come out and said here's the evidence we
did it
but it's all lined up so i'll i'll put
it there i would say it's beyond a
reasonable doubt in my opinion
but to be fair there's a probability
that tucker is wrong about who's leaking
or he was misled
somebody at fox may have leaked it axios
says axios has not confirmed whether any
communications from carlson have been
intercepted
and if so why that think about what that
means
what's with this weird double speak why
can't axio say
axios has not confirmed whether any
communications from carlson
were or i'm sorry why can't they say
they have not confirmed
that the nsa was the source of this
information
what they're saying was his
communications have been intercepted
so that means the the source for
jonathan swan may actually be the nsa
but the nsa didn't say we spied on
tucker just hears information on tucker
if here's the point when the nsa denied
spying on tucker they never came out
right and said we are not reading his
emails we are not reading his tasks
text is not true they said tucker
alleged that we were spying on his
communications and we're planning to
leak them in order to get his show off
the air that allegation is untrue
well the the allegation in that sentence
is the final uh right subject to get his
show off the air right which could have
been hyperbolic or they could have been
like we wanted to damage him
not get him canceled just hurt him
enough that maybe eventually he does
who knows they can argue a million a
million ways why that wasn't true
but they never said we did not intercept
communications from tucker carlson we
are not
spying on him either accidentally or on
purpose right they gave someone weird
double speak or
incidentally right incidentally right
which is actually like the key word in
this case right
because it's really about them spying on
putin
and they incidentally have discovered
that there's an american citizen
involved therefore now
this internationally focused spy agency
can now turn their attention this is all
congruent with everything we've been
talking about here for months and months
and months and months and months
the war on terror coming home coming
home right extremists dude we've been
saying this from for what how long check
check this out they said 2003
2006. axios xio says those sources said
u.s government officials
learned about carlson's effort to secure
the putin interview how
carlson learned the government was aware
of his outreach and that's the basis of
his extraordinary accusation
followed by a rare public denial by the
nsa that he has been targeted wait wait
wait wait wait wait hold on hold on
sources have literally said carlson
learned the government was aware of his
outreach
he's basically confirming there's a
federal agency in some capacity somehow
that was aware of his outreach what
they're saying what they're saying is
is the government is spying on you
tucker
why are you crying about it no one's
someone's objecting to the spying
right they're objecting to the crying
now i want to go back to this statement
from axios
they have can they have not confirmed
whether any communication from carlson
have been intercepted and if so why not
confirmed
that the sentence literally means
nothing so an nsa guy goes to jonathan
swann hypothetically
and says hey you you know you know
tucker carlson is uh trying to meet with
putin
i can confirm that to you right now 100
guaranteed
and swan says how do you know that don't
worry about it okay i can't confirm they
were spying on him but he told me that
if it wasn't the nsa telling jonathan
swan why didn't they also add
the source of this information is not
coming from the nsa no they're
quite literally saying carlson learned
from that the government was aware
us government officials had learned
about this who with access to the
government
was providing information to jonathan
swan that is an interesting question
because
it does suggest that there's a white hat
and a black hat
in operation right now right somebody
telling tucker and somebody talking to
swan at the same time
is it two different people is it the
same person
they go on to say but let me a little
bit of this the nsa's public statement
didn't directly deny that any carlson
communications had been swept up by the
agency
axios submitted a request for comment to
the nsa on wednesday
asking whether the agency would also be
willing to categorically deny that the
nsa intercepted any of carlson's
communications
in the context of monitoring somebody he
was talking to in his effort to set up
an interview with putin
an nsa spokesperson declined to comment
and referred axios back to the earlier
statement carefully worded it says
in other words the nsa is denying the
targeting of carlson but is not denying
that his communications were
incidentally collected
and axios is not telling us who their
source is
whether or not their source is part of
the nsa and they could do that
if i if i had a source who revealed that
jack murphy had stolen my cookies from
the cookie jar
and people were like ian was the source
i could be like ian was not the source
i can confirm that much right right
lydia witnessed
jack and i said i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna out my source you know
but i can certainly say it wasn't ian
that's one person out of the million it
could have been
they could just say our source is not
the nsa
what is not in government what is axios
who what horse do they ride in here
what do they want to see have happen i
don't know how do they slant how do they
lean how do they dress as the tailor
asks
i mean jonathan swan he's the guy who
did that really awful interview with
trump where he was just negative about
literally everything trump said
and he was scowling the whole time at
everything trump said
look we know that they were they are
literally searching
right now oliver dumb dumb darcy
and team they're all searching for who's
the next putin
who's the next hitler who's the next
trump
who's the next evil guy that we have to
destroy
and isn't it funny that the timing on
all this just happened right now
tucker carlson is being named as you
know if tucker hadn't gotten out in
front
of this what would the story have been
story had been
tucker carlson trying to collude
secretly with vladimir putin
he's the russian gate 2.5 yes so so we
already saw
this absolutely hilarious story
where brian stelter in his pathetic
desperate attempt for ratings so if
those aren't familiar he's a guy who
hosts
sunday mornings on cnn it's a little poo
poo show and he was like
on youtube is tucker carlson the new
alex jones
yes and then oliver darcy like tucker
carlson is the new alex jones the funny
thing is oliver never blinked
did you notice that i don't i don't
really notice but a lot of people kept
posting like does this guy blink at all
like he's just standing there staring at
the camera dude's gone nuts
like oliver these these people i wonder
if they
if they like cry at night oliver i know
you're crying dude i
know you're crying well no no but but
think about it like
they've they've they've dug themselves
in so deep to this anti-trump narrative
that there's nothing they can do they
could they could cut
guys it was a big joke um
nah their careers are done done the only
thing they have left is orange man bad
but there's no orange man anymore
they're trying to find one desperately
tucker carlson is the new alex jones
they said
did you see this clip did you see the
clip they did oh with stelter and darcy
salter and darcy on the new
jones of course i did because oliver i
love laughing at you by the way
tucker carlson goes he's like there's
risks in everything of course and even
vaccines and then it pauses
and then it's alex jones you know
yelling about the vaccines i'm like
those aren't even the same statements
your doctor will tell you there can be
adverse reactions like
that's normal then there's what do you
say when he mentions the spying
then it shows an old clip from like the
two thousands of jones like they're
spying money on me it's been admitted
it's happening
and i'm like so you found three or four
things that are somewhat related but
still kind of different and you're
acting like he's
he's verbatim repeating alex jones it
was the most
ridiculous garbage story ever
a few months ago what did they say
tucker carlson is the new donald trump
and they did the same thing showing
tucker
saying things and then trump saying
things and they're like tucker is the
new trump
they've been trying to do that non-stop
i don't think it has anything to do
necessarily uh with politics though
partly i'm sure a lot of activists don't
like that tucker carlson is influential
speaking to young people particularly
huge in the writing especially in the
key demo
i think they're just desperate for an
orange man they ain't no orange man no
more i don't know what to do
they don't know how to to function
unless they've got someone they can
point to and say
hitler hitler hitler hitler hitler and
they're going to try to tie everybody
back to trump because they
they really shot their wad on this you
want you want it right like you can't
get any worse than the things that they
called trump
right right so they got to now call
everybody trump
it's funny that they've they've driven
themselves so insane
i i i will say this the things that
worry me critical race theory in schools
i'm sorry critical rate applied prac
principles that's crap dude it is indeed
yeah
yeah literally so anyway i know i'm with
you dude yeah i'm just giving it back
i know i know literally so anyway that
worries me about the future
but when but michael mouse has a point
when he says look how stupid these
people are
look how absolutely stupid these people
are i i gotta tell you they're they're
they're really stupid
let me show you just how stupid just how
stupid are they tim
two hours ago axios reported
that tucker carlson was seeking an
interview with vladimir putin at the
time he was
accusing that a day of spying on him
stands to reason
somebody leaked communications from
tucker carlson somehow
that he was doing this and who would
have access to it
perhaps it was a hacker who broke into
tucker's email and phone and spoofed it
or something
or perhaps tucker is right tucker's
source said the nsa was spying on him
perhaps that's the case okay so that was
two hours ago the story breaks
evidence to suggest tucker is right
pretty strong evidence
gizmodo writes this story an hour ago
tucker foyers the nsa that means freedom
of information act
it foia means if as a verb to file a
request for the government information
to see what they're doing
gizmodo says the pompadour talk show
host to the face made of plato
has decided to kick things up a notch in
his feud with america
america's surveillance goliath they say
this
it was about two weeks ago that tucker
carlson first claimed without evidence
that not only was the nsa spying on him
and his staff but that it was plotting
to leak his show's internal
communications in an apparent effort to
take it off the air
not long after that the nsa blah blah
blah the whole episode is bizarre for
many reasons
even in today's day and age now it would
appear that the new news anchor in the
show filed an actual foia request
with the spy agency in an apparent
effort to shake loose any evidence
of the government's supposed snooping
and they go on blah blah blah
i'm requesting records the date to
document i look to the story
guess what this dude at gizmodo
lucasropec did not even google search
or even go on twitter before publishing
this story
talk about really
i'm sorry i can't say the word dumb i
gotta say something else i gotta say
um incapable malpractical
no no no no no no i don't wanna say he
did a bad job i want to say that there's
something seriously wrong with his like
uh ability to add numbers together
flawed like
here's here's somebody who said i am
going to publish it not of course he can
probably
blame his editor perhaps he wrote the
story earlier this morning the editor
was sitting on it
let's call the failure gizmodos but
imagine being this guy
and you don't go to your editor and say
news just broke that tucker's
communications did in fact leak somehow
to a journalist at axios perhaps tucker
was
right the whole time they publish a
story
insulting him saying without evidence an
hour
after news breaks suggesting tucker was
telling the truth
that is a whole new level of
failure serious incompetence first of
all
tucker carlson does not have a pompadour
can we like that's just you're
automatically trash and by the way yes
everyone who goes on tv has makeup on
except for me tonight i wish i did yeah
but the rest of it i mean
who has a feud with american
surveillance
goliath huh everyone a journalist has a
feud with his surveillance goliath
like the end of the the headline the sub
the sub headline there
i think is it meant to make the nsa look
bad and tucker look good because that's
how i
feel that's how i i read it information
surveillance goliath they is a feud they
need their their trump men
and so this is gizmodo saying look
tucker is our target
he's an other we hate so just insult him
when you live in the world of corporate
media
no no for real i'm sure that their like
executive editor or their higher-ups
were like
oh we got a story about tucker huh
insult them a little bit rough them up
because that's what
our readers like yeah
plato i hate that guy that's awesome
yeah
i feel bad for i don't know if this guy
actually sometimes the editors make
changes
i hope so yeah well that should be in
the article if they did
they should lay that on the writer if
the editor changed it but who knows who
knows so right now it's on you lucas
because you got the byline
imagine this dude lucas right seven
comments he's like a little kid
and and he's like a big break big big
break
i want to be a journalist when i grow up
it's like bro the story
an hour before you published this broke
providing evidence you got no context on
it like
nothing you guys need to take this down
right no retraction no nothing because
you know what they don't care
but why why insult people like this so
severely
listen if they said the far right or the
conservative or whatever i'd roll my
eyes
but you're allowed to to have somewhat
of a framing device
i don't like it but saying a pomp adored
play-doh face
is just insulting the guy tim it's so
obvious they don't have an
orange man they need a pop adored man
there we go
he doesn't even have a pompadour it's
not true but it doesn't matter
at least trump was orange bro was orange
can we just admit that yes
orange this article is getting read more
right now than it has
stopped showing them did you see the
donald trump's press conference
which one that one today yeah dude was
orange
he was pretty orange he was so orange he
is orange look remember
sitting by the pool and getting tanned
takes real time and effort
true homie doesn't have that time and
effort he goes in that in that thing
and they just go organic he wears those
goggles over his eyes
that's why he's got them little raccoon
eyes around it's a spray tan
i know it it's all right does he bleach
his hair i mean maybe
why it's his hair though it's all right
but why would he want to be orange
it's better than being pale have you
seen joe biden keeper
keeper when you can see the veins and
the ligaments and the sores
and all that i mean dude bros over 70.
things change
liver you don't heal yeah your skin
looks terrible he has calculated
it's better to be orange than to be pale
and dead
yep yeah orange is vibrant
it's better than being like transparent
with your veins and everything coming
right out of your eyes
i look at these news stories and i'm i
i'm feeling pretty good when i want to
see this stuff
pretty good about what the the demise of
the old media
confidence in the rise of new media they
look super professional here you know i
do love too though i
got i gotta admit something else like
we're pretty good at flying under the
radar
yeah i've seen that yesterday no yeah
absolutely who's right right
uh the the main the establishment
so there was an article in axios talking
about the decline of mainstream media
and the rise of independent media
and they're talking about crystalline uh
and cigar with breaking points which has
been taking off tremendously again like
half a million subs in a month the
show's doing massive and they're awesome
so
you know it's awesome for them i don't
even know who they are well they're
great yeah they were they were on the
hills rising
they're fantastic i'm living under a
rock apparently yeah you need a lot but
but they really are great they're really
great it's populist left and right they
do a show together
they they share like a populist view and
then they have their own views on left
and right
but anyway i'm reading this article and
i'm like you know
part of me is saying like why don't why
doesn't anybody take interest in what
we're doing like why isn't this on the
radar
and i've been thinking for a long time
how good that is because it's actually
one of the reasons i reduced the amount
of segments i was doing on my other
channels i was doing
i was doing five per day on one channel
are you down yeah
i cut three out oh nice and weekends are
gone oh wow
yeah yeah uh part of it was i felt like
maximizing
exposure was a weakness it it allowed us
to get more ad traffic
and and and operate the business off
youtube ad revenue
but it also created more exposure which
is
more space to be attacked from and i was
like we need to we need to pull back
we need to focus more on delivering a
better product and not focus on
maximizing viewership
so that's actually in many ways a good
thing we fly under the radar in the
on a lot of these things so when i look
at when i look at the media
they're attacking everybody like crazy
the way they attack andy know like
crazy and i'm like we just kind of do
our thing and no one
there's no smear pieces sometimes it
could be the milk toast nature
of your show though tim we're invincible
milk toast is the new armor and don't
forget the q and the e
in the word i don't i don't know i'm
just kidding with that dude i totally
understand that's why we created the
liminal order that's why we're hoping
so i can get off of the freaking you
know the the chopping block all my guys
can get off the chopping block
we can have constructive productive
conversations and do things inside the
lo that no one can see
it's great like this show how many other
like news people have
people sitting there telling they're
wrong like i'll tell you you're wrong
i don't really tell you no tim you're
wrong i mean not really but i will if
you're wrong but listen listen we've
people humble each other that's what
friendship is and that's true check it
out
we had richie mcginnis i like richard
telling his telling his story about what
happened with kyle rittenhouse
it's one of our most viewed segments
ever happy we get no
no attacks no one attacks us no smears
we have alex jones on the show
twice we have enrique tario on the show
nothing written about us
totally under the radar that's good news
because we're going to be growing this
brand timcast.com we're going to be
expanding that
that's why i bring this up i'm really
confident when i look at the failures of
the media
they're completely unaware of what's
happening unless it fits the
fighting so when you see a lot of this
like drama between
stephen crowder and ethan klein for
instance that's high
level like it's really it's really easy
for the average person to
take sides and get into a fight over
this stuff but we don't really have all
that drama stuff so it's hard for them
to write about
what are they going to say like oh you
know ian he
uh graphene the fed english crown
rothschilds actually smoked dmt
[Laughter]
what do they got right now sometimes
something will pop up and no one cares
yeah you know what it is
i think you look at someone like crowder
very energetic and he'll say things
about specific people ben shapiro will
do the same thing
i don't do that but i don't i should
don't play in the vlog
that's a big part of it yeah so it makes
it very difficult for them to latch onto
anything i think what you said earlier
about
what you use your money on as a
corporation like you get a big influx of
cash do you spend it on marketing what
you already have or do you hire
or create new products and then not
worry as much about the marketing and
the tim cast model so far has been that
not worried about the market we did that
with mines too we didn't market the
thing we just built it and built it and
built it and built it under the radar
now the technology is so robust that it
speaks for itself it's stupid
by the way check it out with the new
matrix messaging it's pretty lit matrix
i gotta say it's gonna and it just keeps
getting better um
that's what my analogy is i'm i'm
feeling real good plus it's a private
corp so you don't have investments so
you don't have the hassle of the
public uh harassment that's the other
crazy thing too that's like
kind of worrying me people will come
here and they'll be like so who's
backing this and i'll be like what do
you mean what do you mean i'll be like
yeah yeah like you know daily wires got
backers breitbart
i'm like nobody i don't know i started a
youtube channel and then hired people
i skateboard bro that's how this
happened yo but but
i i i don't want to talk too much about
us because it's more about the bigger
picture
certainly i'm feeling good and and the
success of timcast.com and everyone
signing people members
gives me confidence in the future it's
probably the most the the most
like illuminating thing when you know
when i hear
bannon and michael males say like we're
gonna win and i start thinking about all
the really bad stuff and i want to get
pulled into that darkness where it's
like all the bad stuff is taking over
and then i stopped and i thought to
myself do i really think teamcast.com is
gonna fail and i'm like no
it's it's taken off like crazy things
are going well nothing's going to change
it's going to keep on this track of
succeeding it's going to plow right
through the darkness
and expand and then shove that darkness
back into the dark corners
i feel the same way man i mean we are
going to win well first of all the other
side has no first principle that is
self-sustaining
okay it's just a self-destructive
self-immolating self-collapsing kind of
process
second of all i can see and feel the
energy building inside the liminal order
that's the liminal hyphen order.com
600 guys all around the world we're all
working every single day to solve all
these problems and make everything
in our lives happier healthy and
wealthier these things are happening all
over the country
all over the world and you're right
about about being
off the radar there's a weird pull
about social media and fame at the
beginning especially you're like oh it's
you know fame that's power yeah no no no
no
fame is a problem fame is a problem
power
you know the ability but by power i mean
the ability to positively affect
change in the world that's what that's
what i'm after
like and that doesn't come with fame
although i will say i got recognized all
over
the state of virginia this weekend
thanks to tim poole well i i can give an
analogy to everybody help them
understand
you ever play 4v4 uh i'm sorry um
battle royale smash brothers four
players smash brothers your play smash
brothers
every man for himself four players so
you know you know what i do
i'm like you guys really want to do this
you want to go up against me
smash brothers but every man for himself
all right
i just go i slowly walk to the corner
and stand there as everyone beats each
other up
and then i just chill and then finally
when the last person's left i'm like yo
you could have come over at any point
but you you ignored me thinking i was
doing nothing
now i got three lives i got zero percent
damage
that's what it's all about oh you get
mixed up in the fray you take a lot of
heat you take a lot of damage hoping
that you'll come out on top
mm-hmm not i have a good story about
this i met with um
courtesy arvin a few years ago when he
was in sort of a quiet period
and he told me he's like look you know
there's no point in in encountering
a predator animal as a predator animal
on the savannah
there's no point in that maybe you guys
fight maybe you clash maybe
bleed and then maybe two months later
you both bleed out and die no
the wise ones they kind of lick and they
just say and they just sort of go
the other way and and i have taken that
to heart that's what the lo the liminal
order is all about
taking your head off the chopping block
going underground
popping up when you want being strategic
about your appearances
about your public message there was this
time at which
starting with bulletin board systems and
telnet and icq and all these things
where you just put everything out there
bro just throw it all out there let's
connect with anybody we can connect with
talk to anybody
now it's like okay i want to
strategically disconnect
i want to build barriers between me and
the rest of the universe and i want to
have a highly curated high trust
environment
in which i can actually get work done i
can change my life i can change the
lives of other people
my family we can build businesses and
products outside of the spotlight
and i think that that's partly you know
the vibe that you're riding on here
you don't be really funny do it like 300
years
there's like you know society is
flourishing and there's flying cars and
space travel
and there's a guy and he's the president
and he's like you know vote for me for
re-election
and you know what would i say a couple
hundred years so it's like 23 something
20 23 24 whatever and he's like vote for
me for reelection and they're like yay
and then he turns around and he walks
into the room and there's a guy with a
liminal order on
patch on and he's like you did really
well very good porter
the order respects your work i mean our
goal here is we have a thousand-year
time horizon you ever heard of the
knights of malta i have
these this is what we're talking about
it was like an ancient actual
sovereignty
what were they they were like a military
force they first came about to protect
pilgrims on their way to the holy land
and in doing that protecting people on
the way to something important
they were able to build armies they
built property they built sovereignty
they built their own nation
thousand years it helps having the
blessing of the pope
that does help yeah but uh absent that
we'll make it work that's that's the
time
perspective that we're working on and uh
we're trying to
be part of the remaking of society right
like networks are the way the society is
going to be
functioning the best part it's going to
be so after this guy like he's running
for president he walks in and there's
some like
emissary from the liminal order and he's
like you've done great work
the order thanks you for your service
and he's like thank you sir
then there's like some guy in the on the
on the virtue net like virtual net and
he's like
the the liminal order controls
everything you need to understand how
powerful they're like oh shut
up there's no liminal order like it's
started by jack murphy
2020 or 2019 that's right it doesn't
exist
thou shalt not speak the name first rule
that's powerful it is is it really the
rule you say the name of all time
no actually i do but if you've noticed
there's no one you've never seen anybody
probably publicly talking about
secret societies it is secret we do
encourage guys to not talk about
it let me take all the heat be out there
as a lightning rod and you just quietly
go about doing your business is changing
the world
let's talk about uh feeling good and
confident and successes right like that
white killed me baby so so we got the
media
spiraling out of control sad and
desperate did you see that there was
there was the ratings for msnbc on
sunday they get like 29
000 even i'm crushing msnbc in the key
demos dude
bro it's not it's not fair to say you're
crushing them when they're getting 29
000
viewers no i am definitely crushing them
i am crushing network news period end of
story that's what i told my mom
now now i'll be fair uh during like
weeknights like rachel maddow gets 3
million
but in the key demo she's getting like
two hundred thousand the key demo being
25 to 55 men with money
basically old people are watching maddow
and tucker but tucker's still getting
twice what cnn
msnbc are getting so anyway look i
watched the media's collapse
and i'm laughing because we're growing
and maybe we won't ever be as big as cnn
was
but it's decentralized these days but
there we go we got something else we got
this big big news
from donald trump himself do it trump
files a class
action lawsuit against facebook twitter
and google for censoring him
demands an end to big text silencing and
blacklisting of conservative voices
and calls for punitive damages for
canceled culture victims
he is also suing the ceos of these
companies
i mean that's it now he made his
appearance uh he was in new jersey
boy did that man look orange very orange
man right there
but hey this is good news now a lot of
people on the left a lot of democrats
are saying
it's doomed to fail there's no way his
suit will succeed
that's not relevant maybe that's true
that's not relevant
how do you win a fight if you never
fight it
you stand there watching somebody poke
and prod and bully and oppress
and you say there's no point in fighting
because we'll lose imagine
imagine this it's like a bug's life you
know was it with the crickets
yeah was that what was it was the
crickets versus i didn't see it
grasshoppers grasshoppers there you go
the grasshoppers are like they outnumber
us a thousand to one if they find out
the system like they're gonna topple us
everybody loves using that analogy of
the left and the right but but think
about it right now
if you're watching these grasshoppers
kick people around these billionaires
these tech oligarchs
push people around and you're like we'll
never win against them
there's no point in fighting
congratulations you're right
whether whether you uh what is it what
is this saying whether you believe you
will succeed or you will fail you're
right yep
you're right now what happens if every
single person who got banned said i'm
filing a suit
i'll probably lose but i'm gonna file a
suit anyway imagine if a million people
filed lawsuits against facebook they
would be they would be buried in legend
in litigation so there was actually i
can't remember if it was patreon or a
couple
patreon ones where they had an automatic
arbitration clause
so that any time anybody filed a
complaint they automatically had to go
to arbitration it was paid for by
patreon
yep so i remember guys like box day and
others were like really rallying people
to try to
take advantage of this the thing about
trump that people loved and loved to
this day
is that dude is a fighter okay he will
fight
that he's not going to take it he's
going to fight he made a lot of mistakes
though
he could have fought better oh of course
but he's at least trying something
right it's just trying something and you
know the first thing that you do in a
lawsuit like this is you do the
spaghetti thing
you throw the spaghetti up against the
wall you cite all the people
individually
all of them personally all their
associates all the different entities
and then you force the other side into
having to now make arguments as to why
they need to dismiss this guy and
dismiss that guy
they spend money there's discovery it's
all part of
the normal process now i have no idea
the legalities of this will chamberlain
probably be the best person to talk
to about this or ron coleman and those
guys
uh who know you know how these lawsuits
are going to go but i like the energy
fight back man fight back i obviously
colluded
right right i i've talked to will who's
uh who's very smart he's a lawyer so he
knows a lot about this
and i've brought up a lot of things to
him where he says that's no good that
maybe that's no good and
i don't know maybe a judge will agree
with that one that that
that right there whether or not you get
a judge to agree with you is the biggest
question
did you make a good enough argument to
convince a judge and what i've seen
across the board from defamation
lawsuits to censorship lawsuits
is the lawyers have made really bad
arguments because they fundamentally
don't understand what they're talking
about
no i i mean disrespect a lot of these
lawyers because some of them have done
good lawsuits that got thrown out
but they don't understand the nature of
the system
they don't understand the attack vectors
i think wikipedia may be one of the
best uh uh um one of the weakest
platforms that could create a hole in
the whole 230 argument
and defamation specifically so um
tell me i got larry singer coming on
tomorrow wikipedia
when you go to wikipedia.com i love
pulling up james o'keefe let me pull up
james o'keefe on wikipedia
veritas is probably about i'm sure it
says very nice and honest and true
things about
that's exactly the point so let me
actually james o'keefe's has got a lot
of bad things in it it's very it's very
it's framed you know kind of
very poorly but actually let me pull up
project veritas
there we go because project veritas
according to wikipedia is a far-right
activist group founded by james o'keefe
it produces deceptively edited videos
undercover operations
we've talked about this a bit like i
like using veritas specifically because
it's all lies and opinion what is
jack what is that what does this say
right here can you read that from
wikipedia the free encyclopedia
oh it doesn't say from you know mega
megadude 539. it doesn't say from
jack murphy live does it no no this
article is
from wikipedia project versus free
encyclopedia from wikipedia
so who's responsible for that defamation
i would say wikipedia
i would argue that i'd say so and i
think no one's
uh you need to sue on that grounds james
o'keefe would need to file a lawsuit
against wikipedia for defamation for oh
i'm sorry for libel
and say that wikipedia called us
accuses of deceptively editing videos
now my understanding is he recently won
over the phrase deceptively edited in
the new york times case yeah
the case has not concluded yet but a
judge said that uh
actually maybe it wasn't new york times
one but i'm pretty sure
he did win a case where he said it
wasn't deceptively edited i could be
wrong though but anyway i digress
i love the way that they've got
citations for far right
and then deceptively edited that's the
way that they're gonna get out of it
right they're going to go to go to that
citation we're just citing i don't think
that major news sources i think an
argument has to be made you got to go to
court you know why
if ian comes to me and says jack murphy
can't do a backflip
and then i go jack murphy can't do a
backflip it's a
fact yeah you told me you're responsible
for that if you did that
just because ian told me and then i go
out and say it and it's a fact
doesn't mean the responsibility doesn't
fall on me anymore well i'm going to
talk to larry sanger co-founder of
of wikipedia tomorrow on jack murphy
live check it out on youtube
maybe it'll uh talk him into filing suit
on behalf of all these people
against his former company that he
started because i'm pretty sure he's not
in favor
oh definitely what's going on there
we've talked to him about i think we
talked to him about this
yeah we did and i think the big
distinction for wikipedia is that it
says it's from wikipedia yeah you can
put all the citations in the world you
want and say don't look at me i was just
citing this source it's like bro
you said it was from you so so donald
trump is suing all these companies
the establishment saying he's doomed to
fail the knight foundation saying he's
doomed to fail which is so insane to me
when did these freedom of the press
defensive little guy
turn into the pro-corporate pro-big tech
non-profits
it was the trump thing man it was trump
it was trump all of a sudden anything
anybody said was bad if you if you
listen to the media sources you grew up
with the future the people that you
trusted
all of a sudden they went ape yeah and
then then the public went ape
could you imagine donald trump runs into
a burning building
comes out singed but carrying a box of
puppies
and then vox.com writes why puppies are
actually bad
exactly like it's a picture of donald
trump and he's like his hair's burned
off he's just bald and scarred and he's
like orange
but i saved the puppies they're the best
puppies everyone agrees they needed to
live
and they're like actually puppies are a
bad thing baby puppies
they have two there's too many of them
people aren't getting them spayed and
neutered
yeah this puppy looks like hitler oh my
gosh and trump saved him
what does that say about trump you know
my problem with with trump kind of what
you said earlier was what people love
about him is that he's a fighter
is that i've known people in my life
that are have like anger issues and
would like get really angry and punch a
wall
and that's like the fighter in them and
it would break the wall or they'd break
their hand
and they wouldn't solve the problem but
they just wanted to hit and fight
and i'm worried that trump just lashes
out
like irrationally and has no hope of of
getting them to change their terms of
service i mean what legal bounds would
anyone have to get a private company to
change their terms of service that's
insane that's fascism it's it's
you need to set precedence yeah you need
you need to do you would so trump files
a lawsuit but it's spaghetti on the wall
the judge says it's a fiscal you know uh
the
the the the allegations one through 100
are all bad but 101 102 103 are good
bring us back an argument around those
that's how it goes
yeah i don't know i don't know that's
that's that's what happened to the kids
with defamation they had like 33 claims
the judge threw out 30 of them they were
kept three and then the company settled
because they were scared of discovery
now tell you what's really interesting
about this lawsuit with trump
there are actually a bunch of people on
the left that are are saying trump
uh that these companies should not get
these cases dismissed you know why
they want facebook and twitter to uh
agree basically let the suit happen and
then move to discovery
subpoena trump get him under oath get
his emails get his documents
around january 6. trump is saying i was
banned on this day for these reasons and
i'm suing
twitter and facebook could be like okay
let's get your emails on that day and
see what you were saying to prove
whether or not
you had the intention that we we thought
you did and then
they get trump's emails i guess we'll
see if that's actually
the uh a flaw in their strategy as they
push forward with the lawsuit i have to
suspect
it's just the the the optimist in me
that
somebody on trump's team might have
suggested that that would be
an outcome or it's actually really
simple maybe trump didn't actually do
any of the things they accused them of
doing
of course yes and so trump's last step i
don't care yeah
yeah okay i think we know what trump's
emails are going to look like
i think do do you there it's going to be
really like
short yeah lazy because he even said
didn't he say he doesn't send emails
yeah smart i mean it is wise why put
anything in writing
you know you know when you're talking to
somebody who's been a little bit
paranoid is when you're texting
and then all of a sudden you get an
audio of an audio message
is that a text that's all i do is i send
audio messages
no i leave everything out of text unless
it is 100 necessary
30 second audio clips to say what i got
to say that's it if you can keep those
and share those maybe fine you're
really putting an extra effort for that
then i guess
i guess audio is better at least there's
context like you can hear my tone of
voice yeah
yeah text twitter doesn't work at all
like
and i think this i don't know if i'm
just biased
maybe that's the case but people on the
left man they really
really have a hard time they have a
really hard time so like
shuan had tweeted something as a joke
sarcastically
about you know i don't know fascism or
something and then i responded with
so you admit it that's like i love
tweeting at people so you admit it
to like if the joke is i'm taking what
they say
out of context to apply it's literal and
it's a joke
the people who follow me totally get
that that's a joke
but uh vosh tweeted tweeted about uh so
china
just uh well i don't i don't know about
china specifically but wechat
banned lgbtq accounts tons of them wiped
it out whip out all this content
and vosh tweeted this is the right move
in furtherance of glorious communism
long-lived president xi jinping
obviously he's not being serious so you
admit it eh that's what i said
so i tweeted so you admit it and then
immediately i knew i had to do this i
replied with
in before anyone thinks either of these
tweets are real right i knew he was
joking
like he's not praising she's making a
joke and then i responded with the joke
obviously
bro so many people were just like you're
so dumb like
why she's mad he's not serious the yeah
so
imagine imagine if these people who are
that dumb
i'm sorry family are your actual family
your actual
mom or your sister or your cousin no
exactly who are reading your tweets and
taking all the jokes seriously
and none of the serious stuff seriously
i'm like you guys just have to stop
reading just stop reading my social
media
because they think they think that the
stuff that is specifically trolley
that is meant to push people away that
is if you're in on it is
obviously a joke and if you're not in on
it good go away
they're part of the good go away crowd
and they're like oh my god
what's happened to you oh we don't even
know you anymore you're a monster
did did a bunch of people like just eat
a brick of fluoride or something
something happened where there's like
people who don't understand
jokes anymore it's that's that's dude
but listen it's not about just
understanding jokes
there are people who can't differentiate
fact from fiction
so there's like people like us where
we're kind of skeptical in a lot of ways
we're well researched not geniuses not
no we don't know everything we're wrong
a lot sure jack just you're the best no
that's ian i'm talking about jack's
genius so so i can be like
here's what i think based on this right
i can have a conversation like let's
let's say i'll have a a debate or a
discussion with like a leftist
personality
and i'll say something like when it
comes to universal healthcare you have
an argument between utilitarianism and
deontological philosophy and he goes i
don't know what that is
and we try to explain it to them and
then maybe i'll be like okay i gotta
dumb it down
for you so maybe i'll use a movie
reference because you're clearly not at
the same level but i'm trying to
communicate
and then they'll start laughing being
like duh he said marvel who are you so
dumb
how do you like you you have these
people that hear brian seltzer go
donald trump is working for russia or
something like that and then you get
chris hayes
where you got jonathan chait saying
trump may have been a russian assets in
the 1980s and they go
whoa and then the mueller report comes
out it's all not true and they go
whoa and then rachel maddow comes out
and says russia again and they go whoa
tucker carlson russia and then meanwhile
people like us
on this side whatever are going like
well something's not right you can't
just say both things like which one's
true which one isn't
but i i seriously think when you look at
the democratic establishment
these are people who either lying many
of them probably are or are just
too dumb to like actually do any of the
work
it's definitely both i mean i think it's
both look at uh uh
um i think ethan klein is a really good
example because what started the feud
with him and stephen crowder is when he
said
bro you don't even got to do any
research just like it's on the cdc you
know what i mean yeah
the kind of people who would be like i
have no responsibility and i don't care
that they're going to go and be like i
don't know dude cnn just said i don't
want to do anything like
why do i have to do work i think that's
that's an example like ethan
maybe dumps out the right word but
ignorant he'll talk about things he
doesn't know about like what he just did
about the cdc
um just don't even think about it that
comment but he's he will also lie
for for comic value like just to have
fun with someone so it's both
do you think like so when he said just
trust the cdc it's easy
do you think if i said to ethan klein yo
bro the tuskegee experiments
you know his answer is going to be i
don't know what that is he's like they
didn't make peanuts
yeah what that's just a joke anyway you
remember
you see that you know getting things
confused with carter and then the peanut
guy and then the other guy he was a
peanut farmer jimmy carter he was now
listen i think what we're seeing
revealed
by the left is their lack of sense
making and they don't have a
sense-making life cycle
so they don't actually have built into
them some way of
of understanding and sifting through all
the information to
come to the right idea so they they have
this they've sort of um
uh uh um uh this this circuited is that
associated or
uncircuited is that a word circuited
disassociated
no no they they've stripped out the
circuitry for sense making they haven't
like
adopted this new skill which we all have
which is you hear it here you hear it
there you go over here you look over
there you listen to 12 different people
experts all of them plus your friend and
your cousin you put it all together
and with actual research and independent
opinions from people from all across the
spectrum
you come to a conclusion yes now that
and that's a process
sense making is a process that comes
through dialogue
and conversation and experimentation
these people on the left are revealing
they have no
sense making skills right they just say
thing and they just move on from the
thing they say a thing they move on from
the thing
they haven't developed the ability to
figure out what's actually real
you need to kind of remove your emotions
from the situation
you're gonna come to it with humility
you're gonna be wrong you're gonna find
out that things you thought were real
aren't real a lot of times and that's
why when we teach sense making in the
liberal order one of the things that we
really focus on
are you hungry are you angry are you
lonely are you tired right now
because this is going to affect the way
that you process this information that
you're receiving
have you ever actually thought about any
of those feelings even
a lot of people no but like a lot of
people will just be like they'll go to
the fridge and there and they'll eat
and no one's ever stopped them and said
are you hungry right now
right and they'll go no i'm just bored
i've been
thinking a lot about anger lately and
like what causes anger a lot of times
it's
sadness or madness and what causes
madness if you're not being listened
to if you feel like you're not being
seen you can become mad and then if
that's untended then you can become
angry
anger's the worst i mean i think anger's
like the worst worst mind state you can
be in
you know you know what they say there's
two things there's two bits of advice
one's family friendly and one's not
family friendly
the first bit of advice is eat before
you go grocery shopping right definitely
because people go in there and like ice
cream ice cream ice cream yeah and it's
like you go home and you're like bro i
can't
eat olive oil i just wanted bananas i
just wanted the ice cream right now so
that's all i want no you're like you you
eat a good meal go to the store and then
you're like i'll get a little bit of
the other one is uh less family friendly
but uh they say before you if you're a
dude before you go on a date you got to
go take care of business
clarity so you get that mental clarity
otherwise start thinking wrong things
right it doesn't always work remove
the sense of urgency yeah we're talking
about that right
get good in the moment make sure you're
not hungry angry lonely or tired make
sure you've squatted
make sure you've slept and then make
sure you balance all these things off
people
a network of people that you have built
i don't think that these guys on the
left have
have demonstrated any ability to sense
make
or to accelerate their process of
observing
uh understanding making a decision and
taking action or the ooda loop right
observe orient decide and act
you know you know what i think about
when i think about the left it's
collectivism
the idea that they're safer if they're
just part of this collective they don't
want to challenge it
their brains just say what they say is
true but i think about the gazelle
as they're running through the fields
and the lines chasing after them
yeah they're safer to pack why because
someone else gets eaten
the survival tactic is to run faster
than the other ones
when you're in a group the line will get
one of them but it ain't going to be you
hopefully wow
that's the mentality and don't run too
fast either right you just don't you
want to be right smack dab in the middle
that is the safest place is in the
middle where all of your friends family
colleagues and associates will get eaten
before you do
because that's what cowards do when
you're on when you're in the collective
you're hoping that when the war comes
other people get killed and it's not you
but guess what
you may be that sacrifice when you're an
individual
it's all on you you might die you might
succeed the line might get you
but it's on you to choose what to do
where to go and how to fight how to
survive
and who's who is easier who what
position is easier to be like hey let's
go to war
like the gazelle in the middle of the
pack yeah or the or the lone one
running on his own like which we were
just talking about this about predators
on the on the
on the savannah it's like we've
encountered each other we can fight
we can maybe name each other or we can
just go like this
and just go about our business i watched
two bears go at it and they bit each
other's faces
and like ripped each other's faces open
and then they were just like walking
around breathing heavy
just bleeding faces like what was the
point of that and
fortunately humans have kind of figured
out what's why would we beat each other
up and break each other
when just weaken each other like there's
no point what happens sometimes
if you're if you're dying and you need
stuff you gotta take it from somebody
i'd say what happens frequently
in fact it's all throughout history ever
since the very beginning we are a
war-like people
we're war people we're war mongers the
christians have a god
that says i am a god of war
i read this in the bible the other day
it's right there so is this all
about all this social confrontation like
simulated warfare like psychological
we're doing it to each other it's not
just a conflict conflict comes in many
forms
i don't i don't like collectivism i've
been in unions
and you know what i've been held back by
them that caused me problems
and they always come back and they say
things like if it wasn't for the union
you wouldn't have x y and z and i'm like
no no if it wasn't for the union you
wouldn't have x y and z so you're
advocating for it me
i'll do fine i can leave and i got no
problems to worry about the problem i
have to worry about is being dragged
down
attached to heavy weights that are you
and your group i'm better off on my own
sounds like the public school system i
think a lot of people are just like i
can't succeed unless i band together
with other people
it's really hard the union's thing is
really hard because look at the
beginning
unions were really important they used
to chain up factories
they used to let factories burn down
they used to not let kids take breaks
they used to make people work eight
hours
right eight days a week 25 hours a day
that's different but the unions had to
actually fix that
i'm not saying that you never have any
collective no i know i'm just saying i
don't know
you brought up unions and i and i
struggle with this right because they
solve
serious problems no no and now they're
creating problems
you're talking about something else a
hundred years ago same word unions today
are like corporate machines to siphon
money away from dumb people dude i know
who randy weingarten is man
i know what's going on who is randy
wagner she's the leading
uh union rep for the teachers
and collectively with the nea and the
other one they're about ready to say
that they're
not going to work this fall unless all
students are vaccinated yep
good schools are terrible teaching kids
i'm just saying i'm watching this lady
just destroy the whole freaking
education market because she's
she's advocating for her for what she
thinks the teachers as professionals
need rather than what the kids need
i need to clarify something too because
i tweeted that they're not teaching
critical race theory they're teaching
critical rate applied principles
and that's because somebody super
chatted us i have been saying this for a
while now
and i was criticized for it and i think
people on twitter like you know james
tweeted this
i don't think they've actually seen or
listened to my podcast where i've talked
about this
i've criticized christopher ruffo and
james lindsay for saying critical race
theory and over and over again i respect
the work they're doing tremendously
but when you say critical race theory
they come out and they show you the book
critical race theory by kimberly
crenshaw and they say
no student has been taught from this
book that's insane
and so you look at the interviews and i
came out right away saying they're not
teaching critical race theory they're
teaching pre it's praxis it's theory and
practice
so i've long said critical theory and
practice it is the
indoctrination through the ideologies of
critical race theory not directly
critical race theory
and it's important to use language that
specifically can't hide from like
perhaps identitarianism
love that word by the way tyrionism
because then like what's that it's like
people who believe that identity or race
but right specifically should be the the
principal factor in how the rules the
lessons
go and they're teaching kids to view the
world based on race
most people are going to be like no i
don't like that as a joke
i said we need critical race practice i
was like it's crap
and then someone said critical race
applied prince i don't think we need the
applied because
race has an r and an a in it so you have
your c r a
p critical james lindsay did you put a
little a yeah yeah
applied critical race applied principles
are insane
it's crap they're not teaching crt
they're
doing crt on the students which is a
which is a very fine distinction i
understand that but i'm going to have
both
lindsay and roofo on my show on first
week of
of july i believe or no late first week
of august thanks
thank you schedule i hope you guys talk
about the delineation between applying
the the practice and teaching the theory
that that is big now they're talking
about it more
praxis um but praxis is a word defined
to confuse regular people so you also
don't want to use that use the word
practice they say
praxis because it is a dog whistle that
regular people won't
understand and their allies do
understand
you need to use language and i'll admit
identitarianism
a lot of people would understand either
the point is that's exactly their tactic
let's just talk about this for one quick
second though i
there has been amongst the people who
are fighting this
an argument an internecine battle as it
were
about people saying that crt is
explicitly
anti-white or not
and i would just like to interject some
nuance here
crt is definitely explicitly anti-white
but not as its primary goal its primary
goal is to disrupt and to take power
so they're just sort of using the
anti-whiteness as a way for them to take
the power that they want
which is really to inject a false
consciousness to do this class war that
they're doing so
so it's at once auntie white and not
who's who's saying it's
it's not anti-white uh there are
plenty of folks actually within the even
on the right side who are arguing about
that
that's just completely and factually
well if you were like in nigeria
you're saying it is critical race theory
is rooted in critical theory
which is the idea of the oppressed and
the oppressors right it has nothing to
do
with
critical race theory built upon the
marxist ideology of oppressed and
oppressor
by introducing race as the primary
component not class
right marx felt that there was the
bourgeoisie the proletariat it was the
wealthy elites versus the poor workers
and the critical race theorists said
these philosophers or these these
individuals did not understand
racial politics in the united states and
in the west thus we need a framework
that builds upon their ideas
incorporating racism from the united
states which
is there are oppressed and oppressors
and the oppressors are
all white but if you think of ancient
cultures
um if you were applying this practice
like in northern africa where it was
like a black population with a king
and then they had like white slaves from
like italy and
it would greece and rome it would be
anti-black no it wouldn't
because you'd be like the power
structure is black they're they're
subjugating white that is not critical
race theory you didn't read it but
they say whiteness is property literally
the word white
whiteness is proper they were from the
90s they wrote this a long time ago
what you're saying is if they wanted to
view race as a president oppressor it
could be different it could be but they
didn't write that
you so if you want to make ian race
theory by all means go ahead and do it
and you can build upon critical race
theory
the critical race theorists have
literally stated whiteness
whiteness they write books
anti-whiteness whiteness is a problem
they said whiteness is a tangible
physical property it is an
asset individuals have that grants them
things right
you could also apply critical theory to
race and it not be about that i don't
care what they call it if they want to
call it critical race
so you're not talking about what we're
talking about i'm not using the big
capital letters i'm talking about what
critical race theory is it could be
about non
any race okay ian you're talking about
something you're talking about something
a term they've coined
i think i think you're both right which
is the nuance i'm trying to inject here
which is that
the the folks like kendy and and uh
robin and all these and crenshaw and
whatever
they are actually occupied brains
they've their brains have been occupied
by the peep the class people
the critical people right the people
that want to just use the oppressor
oppressor model to upset the power
structure so that they can take power
race is just a new vector so all those
folks are 100 sincere in what they're
saying it's a trip up
it is that's what i'm saying it's both
it's both
it's at once neither and both at the
same time which makes it very hard and
difficult to discuss
there is a class-based divide you've got
the political class the the industrial
class
and the regular people who are being
jammed in the gutter and beaten down
having their jobs sent overseas these
people occupy seats of government
through their wealthy connections they
should wear all the patches for all
their sponsors
so what do they do when occupy wall
street pops its ugly head they say
introduce critical race theory what did
that do it took that idea of class-based
problems
and flipped it sideways so now poor
people are fighting poor people
and yes whiteness is a core component of
this it is inherently a us ideology
that seeks to address the the marx
marxist id
marxist views through the lens of
western race politics what i don't get
is yes
if a kid is born a white kid is born to
a broken home with a mother that he
never sees that's so poor
and and his mom's a junkie a heroin
junkie he's way
less privileged than a black kid that's
born a two a man and a woman
affluent super wealthy educated awesome
friends
the number one privilege in america is i
have a dad privilege
that is the number one privilege in
america which is why we should have a
whole month dedicated to fathers
which is why june should be fatherhood
month
just call it that celebrate it imagine
if we spent
the money now look i have gay friends
i've got gay family members i believe
the gay people should be able to get
married and i have all the
all the emotion in the world for them to
have all the rights that they want pride
is now
totally f'ed up okay hrc is totally f'ed
up
there are people that i know that are
that are homosexual
that don't even want to call themselves
gay anymore
for how screwed up the gay thing has
become what do you mean
politically speaking the politics of the
politics of it that they're they're
they're gay men they're married to gay
men they they love
men but they don't even want to identify
as gay anymore because
the human rights commission and pride
and all that stuff is so political and
so
been so hijacked but imagine if we spent
the money
corporate sponsorship how much corporate
money went into sponsoring pride
which involves kink at parades in front
of children
how much money went into that versus how
much money
could go into sponsoring fatherhood it's
simple bro and what kind of spillover
effect would that have
don't worry about that you should just
tell all of your people to start
celebrating june as well i do
i do at june as fatherhood month that's
it that's it you build the culture
and instead of uh people going like the
government should mandate this
the government should decree this we'll
just do it yeah we will literally do it
and say hey
june is the month of fatherhood we
literally do it and it's my favorite
month
july should be the month of motherhood
do it and it should cherish the feminine
the the the nurturing the the positive
aspects of femininity that are being
washed away
by intersectionality feminism gender
theory
and the critical race theorists their
weird overlap with gender
we should respect both parents i think
that that weird overlap with gender is a
good sign of what i'm talking about
which is it's really not actually about
race
it's really not about gender it's really
just about
power i think it's i think but it is
anti-white at the same time
it is anti-white in its current
iteration in its current iteration in a
way what i guess you're saying there is
no critical race theory that's ever been
written that wasn't anti-white
no you're you're like critical race
theory yes but
theory in itself it would be like if if
a guy came up and said
i've come up with something called race
theory which is how to win a race as
fast as possible and you went
actually race theories about the color
of your skin he'd be like uh
no no no like i'm i've literally created
this i've wrote a book about it
it's about running fast and you went
nope you're wrong like
dude these people explained this very
explicitly what critical race theory is
those are just three common words if you
want to create your own theory of the
same phrase to confuse people and
and tear away that's what i'm doing here
and break away from the argument
to give them power and to obviously i
don't like playing by their definitions
i i think that's an automatic loss
so i don't do that the point is when
people say critical race theory is not
anti-white they're empowering the
critical race theorists ah
i see yeah you don't want to say it's
not what they say it is you want to say
it's something else
well we need to know what it is we need
to define what we're targeting one of
the clever things they do
is screw with semantics on purpose so
that you can't fight it
that's why they're like we want to teach
critical race theory in schools and you
go
don't teach critical race theory in
schools they go we're not teaching
critical race theory in schools
we're just doing we're applying that's
right then they brag about praxis
and they're like they've gone on tv and
said praxis in schools and all that
stuff
and regular people are just confused by
that and they don't hear any opposition
to it praxeology is like
trying to state just like the natural
occurrence or observation of things in
the universe right it's about like
just analyzing things as they exist it's
not about
promoting something it's not about an
ideology it's not about advancing
something which why
why for them it's like a strategic
retreat into something that they feel
like they can't be
critical race praxis is the application
of theory that's what it means
so when they're in schools and uh
you know they're asking you questions
that are based on this ideology
they're implementing the theory the way
i describe it is imagine if you went to
school
imagine if your kid went to school and
they came back with a workbook about
you know self-improvement and being a
better person and it said and it said in
the book
explain why jesus is great
they didn't read the gospel they didn't
cite anything from the bible
they didn't say to go to church on
sunday they want you to work to explain
why jesus is good
imagine if they wrote why does not
having faith in jesus make you feel sad
and then you have to write it fill in
the blank
that's what they're doing with critical
race applied principles right the whole
prompt is already right there in the
question
yeah at the end of the day to be true
after you realize how racist you've been
do you feel good bad or very bad yeah
so what they're doing is they've gone
into schools they've built curriculums
specifically around
this ideology which as far as i'm
concerned is is a non-theistic religion
and they're desperately trying to use
definitions to hide what they're doing
so if you go to a uh and really the
whole critical race theory
and its applied principles are racist
towards everybody to be completely
honest
but they specifically use the word
whiteness targeting white people as the
oppressor
so what happens if you allow them to
change the definition and start
defending them saying well i guess it
could
be about any country like in china the
you know the han chinese are pressing
the uyghur muslims and the falun gong
and stuff like that so critical race is
actually not that bad no no no
that word that phrase that book is
specifically about western racial
politics right
so when a little kid comes home from
school and the mother says what did you
learn he says critical race theory and
then she hears ian's definition she goes
that's not so bad
but when she hears what it actually is
that that little kid says mom you're
evil and i hate your guts
because the book said white people are
bad then she's gonna be like
that's what they're teaching you so is
it when they say whiteness is bad but
you don't have to be white
to exhibit whiteness you can be a black
person exhibiting whiteness semantic
manipulation
when you tell someone a white person
what do they think do they think a black
person of course not
do they think an asian person of course
they don't they imagine a a white dude
with brown hair or whatever
so they're telling kids white white
white white white and then when the
parents go
why are you telling kids that white
people are evil no no
we don't mean your skin we mean just
like
the the the the people with power
and they go oh okay i guess
it's a it's a way to manipulate people
but it's very simple
when they say whiteness and they say
blackness
and they say black and brown there's no
argument that they're not talking about
white people they say black and brown
people
are they referring to luke rotkowski
who's got blonde hair and blue eyes
apparently he's slavic so that counts no
of course not if luke was walking down
the street
they would say he was white and if he
argued against them at the very least
they'd say you're white
passing they tell me i'm white passing
therefore i have white privilege
but it's not about being white it's a
it's it's about the concept of whiteness
no it isn't that's a lie
to trick dumb parents who don't realize
their children are being indoctrinated
to be identitarians
to effectively be akin to nazis
authoritarian race-based policy screw
that i think one of
i think one of the ways it's obvious
that it's about power more than anything
is the way that they just took
everything about america
and then they said this is whiteness and
it's bad right
it's like let's just we want to destroy
this country and take it over for
ourselves and we want all the money we
want
all the prestige we want all the
benefits so what do we do
we say oh all the things that made
america great
we call them white now and now we call
them racist
you had mentioned before that the united
states was a white religious ethno state
basically
in its formation that was the point i
mean basically it says right there in
the original founding documents that
we've created this country for us and
for our posterity
and who was it created by they call the
native american savages
yeah who was it created by i was created
by a bunch of bunch of white guys yeah
sure there were some catholics in
maryland
there's some protestants up in up in new
england but like
basically it was a bunch of white dudes
and they it says right in the document
posterity what does that mean for our
kids and black people are like worth
three-fifths of a human or something
like this
that came later this is a really
difficult thing i mean clearly it's
difficult but like those folks wouldn't
have been in the united states if it
wasn't for the fact that
for slavery right they just wouldn't
have been there thomas jefferson blamed
the king for
that i believe the he said slavery on
the original draft of the
declaration one of the complaints he had
was that the king
had enacted the transatlantic atlantic
slave trade violating human decency
by enslaving people who had not offended
him in any way
and then brought them to the colonies
imposing that evil upon the colonies
and then asking them to take up arms
against the colonists who
in exchange for the freedom that was
stolen from them
it was removed because thomas jefferson
because the founding fathers knew they
needed the support of south carolina and
georgia
if there was going to be an actual fight
for independence they thought they were
going to lose anyway
i think it's really sad that he didn't
include that and also say a bit
hypocritical of the guy because on his
deathbed he didn't free any of his
slaves he had ton
like he over 600 so the point is bro
there are a lot of people who came out
and were saying like they were offended
that people had criticized the
the the founding documents as npr said
the founding documents had flaws and i'm
like
sure yeah but it planted great seeds and
through those seeds of freedom we fought
and abraham lincoln cited the founding
fathers ideas
as to why we're all credited equal and
frederick douglass said i want to make
you
live up to your own standards brilliant
so some guy plants a fugly seed and
through cultivation and nurturing
we've developed a very beautiful crop
it's been amazing
now they're trying to go back and say
look how bad this was in the beginning
yeah well we've kind of fought really
hard to fix all those things right
right and and i think that we ended like
the transatlantic slave trade pretty
early and banned the new sales and like
we're constantly making progress on that
from the jump at the very beginning and
and this is the part that is just
infuriating you can see it in every
instance they take today's standards
and try to apply them to somebody from
400 years ago
when the best you can ask of somebody in
history
is did you make some element of
incremental change
yeah and even like five or six years ago
don't use today's
rules and and beliefs to blame people
for things they said on the internet
eight years ago
like we thank you for screaming the
n-word ten years ago it was fine
a lot yeah it was comedy i mean george
carlin
andrew dice clay these guys would be
their families would be cancelled if we
held them to today's i don't know how
the young turks still exist
the name of their program is effectively
the hitler youth dude i was just reading
about
the indian genocide and the young ones
the the ottoman empire had this
group called the young turks that
basically took all these armenians and
marched them
south and millions and 1.6 million
armenians died in this and they still to
this day say it's that wasn't a genocide
if if there's any like good example of
grifting i think it's definitely the
young turks glenn greenwald
jimmy dore aaron mate that have there's
been this big feud going on between the
young turks and them
and genter comes out and tweets it's the
alt left
and they made these false out of context
accusations which then the alt-right
started saying and i'm just like bro
the the alt left it was a nebulous term
from a few years ago people tried to
work and no one really uses it and the
alt-right has literally nothing to do
with why people don't like you jank
yogurt accused air mate
of being paid by the russians and anna
casparian said something like he seems
to be working for dictators
it was a smear because they didn't like
that he was
the the journalism he does it sparked
this huge feud
i got to say you look back at the
history of the young turks the things
jack yuger has said
about women he got cancelled from the
justice democrats over it
the videos of him talking about women
and their their junk
and insulting like this the things he
said
i actually don't care he's allowed to
have his opinions and oftentimes he was
joking but he's dropped racial slurs
repeatedly the name of their
show is effectively the hitler youth yet
they just don't care
they don't care so when he comes out and
he's like these are unfounded
accusations against us i'm like bro
you're
you literally work for a company that's
like like effectively praising genocide
you know like you've named yourself
after a group that committed a genocide
uh you know i don't think you're serious
when you're talking about reform
and how people change because you didn't
well i don't know i mean he has and i
don't hear him screaming the n-word
anymore but
anyway the my original point i guess is
just don't we're not i'm not
whatever people said crazy stuff in the
past let it go today is today it's a
different this is different political
climate this is my point
here's a guy who won't change the name
of his company
and he could he could here's a guy who
went on
the old and defended child stripping
he did oh of course they'll call it
something else i don't care what they
call it the fact is
there's a little kid who was at a club
full of adults taking his clothes off
and they're throwing money out getting
money
he wasn't he still had he still had uh
like undergarments on
but as a little boy and they did a whole
segment defending it probably more than
one jordan clapper of comedy central did
that as well
and i'm like at a certain point you
realize what these people do
they're not progressive they're just
what
the their path of least resistance when
the media says you're allowed to make
these jokes it's edgy and it's fun
oh they go on they say every racial slur
in the book they make fun of women
they show that they were talking about
like you know um
bottom shots of women climbing out of
cars that's one thing they're getting
heat for
nowadays they're like we won't do that
because we're principled and we oppose
misogyny no you don't
you're literally just saying lowest
common denominator left talking points
to fit in they're opinions didn't change
no no no they're not
jimmy dore he's a comedian yeah they're
not they're they're news presenters
yeah that's what they call themselves
i'll tell you this when i have a video
from six seven years ago where i'm like
segregated graduations are a bad thing
and today i'm like
segregated graduations are a bad thing
you hypocrite you have the same position
right i'm using a different definition
for the word segment now hold on
i have positions that have changed i
used to be like gun control maybe now
i'm like no gun control boom free guns
for children and things like that
that's that's not a path of least
resistance for anybody the popular
mainstream narrative is to be for gun
control if anything i've become more
contrarian in opposition
they've become more establishment say
whatever needs to be said
we'll just say whatever you don't want
no opinions i want to ask chank about
2016 when hillary's emails came out and
it showed that they were like pushing
bernie sanders out of the race
because that was when i saw chang like
something snapped in his brain
and he became almost sociopathic like
having a hard time
accepting the d i mean i know he knows
that there's corruption in dnc but i
want to just go deep on his brain
i'll i'll give him some credit he he
recently did an interview with the hill
where he said the democratic
establishment just lies all the time
he's completely cracked about that i
just think his whole bit is
stay where it's safe all the time and so
he's like we're
we're changing our opinions for
principles like no you're not you're
just staying in the safe you're staying
in the safest possible place you can
when edginess was fun you were in it now
it put pc
you're in it do something counter for
once that's interesting uh
perspective on the overton window for
them yeah the overton window for them
has moved dramatically
to now where even these guys that are
leftists
who used to make jokes all the time
about language and be
what we would consider non-politically
correct today now the overton window has
shifted so
far that they have to disavow like their
entire back catalog
and just adopt a whole new system of
language and thought in order to stay
acceptable that's what you get when
you're trying to stay inside the overton
window you know what's more fun
pushing the overton window in different
directions that's more fun
i love it uh i'll i'll absolutely stand
up
for myself and my principles i
criticized andy no over him going on on
the ground
into into the fray with antifa long
story short
they you know i i expressed my views and
i got a lot of flack for it
and i got called a grifter with no
principles for
for what was i was i trying to build a
leftist audience
these people hate me no it's because i'm
standing up for what i believe in even
if it's unpopular
even if it's a threat to to my f my even
if there are people who follow me like
i'm going to unfollow you i'm like
look man i can only tell you how i feel
i made it i made a tweet about anonymity
and people took it out of context that
was funny and i'm just going to say what
i think dude and if you don't want to
hear it i'm sorry like you don't have to
you're not somewhere else
i appreciate you guys watching if you
did but if you want to watch someone
who's going to say tribalist opinions go
watch the young turks
it's funny people i do the same thing
and people will accuse me of punching
right
or or being a grifter or being
controlled opposition
yeah i'm controlled opposition i i love
it when i get that one because basically
it just means somebody on the far
right doesn't like the fact that i'm
boxing them out and saying
no we don't really want you over here
you're hurting us
this big tent does not include you okay
and then they call me controlled
opposition which is hilarious like
how am i being controlled what are they
giving me are they giving me access and
prestige
can i have my blue check please i got
denied are they giving me money and
support and resources
no are they giving me distribution no
are they shadow banning me yes are they
signing my
my my shares and all that yes how am i
controlled opposition
it's a non-thing you're the trojan horse
that's what i think of myself
you're contr you've allowed yourself to
become what seems like
you know safe but then when they let you
into the city that you re they realize
you were there to
i mean that i kind of changed that's
what i'm trying to do now i've reached
such a bigger audience a more mainstream
audience
that i can drop like red pill stuff from
10 10 years ago
and it's like just old hat stuff that we
talked got so tired of even talking
about
that now i'm in an audience now where
it's like fresh news to people oh yeah
yeah
it's fascinating actually it's like oh
my life's very easy i just have to
remember
we were talking about 2010 and now the
mainstream is actually ready for that in
2021 because
all the things that we said were
happening at that time back in 2010 all
the crazy
feminist conspiracies and all that it's
all come true
i got i got something to say to the
young turks you know
he called jimmy doremonster let's fight
that's what he's so so i i saw
jenk yuger at uh politicon couple years
ago and they had published
they did a video about this fake bit of
research claiming that
there was it's called the alternative
influencer network they put my name
right in the middle
it was the most ridiculous bs they
claimed that i had done interviews with
people i'd never met before
they claimed that i did a youtube video
with steph and milan you i'd never met
the guy
and so when they did a video and they
show the screenshot my name's in the
middle
i saw jenk standing in a hallway and i
was like hey you got a second and he's
like oh hold on i'm busy
and he was talking to someone and after
he's done i was like i just wanted to
mention like you guys i dm'd you about
this
because i saw i'd seen him at vidcon
before and we were talking and shaking
his hand i told him that like
i bought ads on his channel before and
youtube was like stifling them
and so i was like hey you guys did this
video about the the alternative
influencer network or something that
included me like i don't i don't know
what your beef is with dave rubin or
anything i just don't want to be
involved
and he was like i don't know i don't
know what you're talking about and i was
like dude i'm trying to ask you to like
not include me in it and then all of a
sudden
he snapped started screaming at me what
happened to you man you have changed
well he's yelling at me on all this
everyone starts filming and i'm like why
are you yelling at me
i didn't say anything mean to you ever
at all in fact i was i was being
respectful to him on youtube as well
dude snap claimed i changed so i got a
message
if dave rubin jimmy dore tim poole glenn
greenwald michael tracy air mate
are all changing around you maybe it's
you who need to check your boots
maybe you're started by sycophants who
are just blowing smoke up your ass
and telling you what you want to hear
and the people who leave your presence
all of a sudden are like yo
you're nuts jimmy dore leaves the young
turks and all of a sudden he's like
here's what's happening
and chang's like why did he change and
dave rubin leaves the young turks
why did dave change i was never anything
to do with young turks but all of a
sudden
jenkins shocked tim poole changed glenn
greenwald what happened to you
no no no no nothing happened to us
something happened to you
look at your old videos we we're no
you're just saying what is safe for the
establishment
and i think that's true of ethan klein
as well dude used to be edgy
now he's safe they're too scared to risk
anything
to stand up for anything you don't have
to that's fine by me
you want to protect your network and you
want to be you want to be some kind of
progressive
you know channel and just say whatever
the tribe wants you to say
fine that's fine but stop acting shocked
when everyone else who leaves your
presence starts saying things that shock
you
because it may just be that you're
surrounded by yes men and still are yeah
you know what's a much easier brand
image to maintain
one of seeking knowledge or truth oh
that's the brand oh which means i'm
going to change
and evolve that's all part of the plan
we're on a journey we're trying to
discover the truth we're trying to learn
what's really happening we're trying to
create
a mental model of the world that makes
it so we're not insane
that's much easier than to say i'm an
ideologue on this idea and i can't
change they box themselves i'm not
i'm not trying to make them seem any
better than they are
but they're boxed in and anybody on the
right is the same way totally boxed in
if you haven't set yourself up in a way
that you're just going to evolve
which is what humans do which is a
totally natural thing to do
yes i have more information on that
matter so my opinion has changed
that's great my opinion changed quite a
bit you know talking to michael malus
and people like libertarians are
tweeting at him like you you got tim
good job
because i was like abolish the police
bro i'm like watching cops confiscate
guns from law-abiding citizens to uphold
you i'm watching these ridiculous laws
i'm watching the capital police
dude you're the one that they were
referencing when they said that the
right
was claiming that they needed to fund
the police remember that
when the press secretary gets up there
and she's like it's been the republicans
and the conservatives trying to defund
the police this entire time
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah they're
talking about you no johnny views
here's my point capitol police capitol
police
dc capital police are setting up field
offices in california and florida
they're expanding nationwide the capitol
police issued a press release saying
they're gonna be expanding into an
intelligence-based protective agency
yeah because the war on terror is coming
home so my stance has been
not the same as the left that they're
evil oppressors and shut them down it's
that now the good cops are leaving
and the cops who are staying are are a
lot of them are dirty no the good cops
yase fueron spanish they already left
right they're gone so let's not sit back
and be like defend the institution i'm
like nah
because now you're going to get capital
police hunting down quote unquote
patriots
here's here's my prediction i could be
wrong about this but i'll give you a
prediction oh thank god i didn't go that
day
capitol police yeah capital police are
investigating and the feds are tracking
down the people who went in the building
the capital police are setting up field
offices do you think this will stop
or do you think that once they get the
600 people they're gonna say
now we're gonna go after those who
provided material to support to these
people no dude we have a very
extreme hardcore concrete bulletproof
example of the way the government once
they set up these kind of things
they shut them down in due time right
this thing in cuba it's guantanamo bay
they set it up right after 9 11 they put
prisoners in there they closed it down
as soon as they were done
and then that was it wait what what oh
no it's still up wait i'm sorry
wait what was that wait they didn't
close down squadron is still
open i remember honestly
i remember when uh i was in new york
when they announced that they got
osama and uh obama came out and he was
like the war on terror was over
and i was like wow they just ended it
hey
oh wait that didn't happen either no so
here's my way did he really say that
no i was like they didn't assassinate
him the next day
so so here's what i'm saying the capital
police
they're going to go after the rioters
then they're going to say the people
provided material support
then they're going to say we need to
expand more offices to
stop to be preemptive to prevent these
things from happening ever again
the war on terror comes home right and
then when they actually talk to a guy
like omar mateen
and they know that he wants to go around
killing people they're just going to let
him go
because that's actually not what they're
really after would that guy do i shot up
the uh the orlando nightclub
which wasn't actually a gay motivated
thing he was just like
nearest nightclub and it turned out to
be that one full of gay people and so it
became like a gay massacre when really
it wasn't
yeah he was a tragedy he was he was a he
was a a
like a a person of interest or whatever
a technical term would probably not use
that right
to the fbi they knew him in advance
he scoped out that nightclub he murdered
the people in there and then they
retrofitted it to be like a gay guy
i remember who it was um but someone
said that
uh they they said the united states
needed some kind of 9 11 like attack
in their opinions as a republican to
remind people
why we have the security statement wait
they said this after 9 11
yeah they were like it's almost like we
just need it to happen so that people
remember exactly what you know we're
fighting for whatever
something like that i mean look it's
funny like we we've been on top of this
for
a long time we've been you know i and
have you talked to cash i talked to cash
patel also was
on the national security council head of
counter and terrorism
i asked some point blank is there any
evidence
that white nationalism terror is the
biggest threat facing america
zero none this is the guy number one
national security council in charge of
counterterrorism
the secretary i'm sorry the chief of
staff for the secretary of defense
this guy was in there he has all the
intel
and also he'd be the first person to
complain about this fisa crap with uh
tucker
because he used fisa to actually go
after terrorists so he knows
this is why nothing we've been talking
about this i'm sorry i just finished
this thought
we've been talking about this for years
basically and now it's actually
happening and we still have to talk
about it because not everybody knows
i feel like we're beating uh we're
banging on a broken drum
no that doesn't work my mixed metaphor
this is why i feel like
there are two great possibilities of
either an authoritarian takeover
or a civil war because you look at what
they're saying about
white supremacy in the far right which
is just fundamentally absurd and not
true
what they're saying about insurrection
it's the six-month anniversary and the
guy's like holding up his suit he's like
this is the suit i wore on that day
runs an article where they're like
journalists choking up in tears
see i i don't even want to go back in
the building six months later it is the
most
insane garbage why they don't want trump
to come back
they need to say what are they saying
now a quote from trump about hitler
i'm not even going to repeat it it's
like the most absurd fake news
they're desperately trying to maintain
the narrative white supremacy
we're in a lowly year just you wait next
year 2023
2024 it is going to be insane i wouldn't
be surprised
if these capital police officers pop up
all over the country they arrest people
for these communications
they go on forums like you know
patriots.win which used to be the donald
and they'll say like who wants to go
commit this act and then people will say
something and then they'll arrest them
then they'll make some small stupid
tweet into a
massive indictment and the news will be
like extremists were talking about doing
x y z
the fbi will say who wants to do x y and
z and some guy will be like
sounds cool they'll arrest the guy and
say he was advocating for this deadness
he was planning it
we caught their communications we can't
release those to the public though
then they're gonna say trump is
inspiring this it's gonna get worse if
you vote for him
this is what you're gonna get
black pills falling all over my head
i didn't say we were going to lose pills
it's going to be a struggle
i didn't say we're going to lose it's
going to be i said i'm actually i'm
actually confident watching the media
fail now they'll try this stuff but look
how pathetic it is
when oliver darcy stands there with no
blinking yeah but nobody's watching them
the shift is happening their power is
dwindling that's true
they're going to try it the federal
government's going to try it you know
what they don't need the media anymore
you know why because they got your
four-year-old
that's right yeah you know who said that
who said what what was that i got your
children oh no hitler
yeah it's a quote from hitler oh well
they have our children
i was thinking you played civilization i
know you've played civ before
you can go into a golden age we're in a
golden age right now that happens when a
bunch of great people get together
you can opt to use them to start a
golden age
last 20 30 40 years we are literally in
a golden age we're in a golden age
the internet internet video has allowed
us to unite all these great minds so we
formed a golden age now we're still
facing trauma and struggle but we're in
a golden age while we're doing it so we
have these
bonuses a golden age is basically a
period of great economic prosperity and
no war we've been in that for some time
right now
you can be in one you can be in a war
and still be in a golden age right right
yeah the war in afghanistan is not a
real
it's not it's not like no one's storming
the u.s borders
we don't have germany bombing america we
are in
a series of conflicts but the general
idea is
perhaps you can say right now we're not
in a golden age because of the conflicts
we've seen with china and russia
and international disputes and
everything like that but this country
only
for recently i mean we're now entering
the fourth turning for a long time
we were just sure the u.s goes out and
blows stuff up yo there was
there was 10 years 1991 to 2001
that was it that was a golden time
period
right we didn't have any wars gold war
was well i don't know i understand what
you're saying but like just in practical
you could be in a total war this is a
semantic misunderstanding
when i say no wars i'm talking about the
us actually fighting for
survival but you could do that during a
golden age some countries thrive during
war in a golden age like ancient persia
was really in the game they're
extremely they can move now i'm not
talking about the game i'm talking about
the actual historical understanding of
gold
the metaphor is you can enter a golden
age during war
during a war time period and if you do
you're going to be much better equipped
to win the war all right so what you're
basically saying is that we're all the
individual pieces of voltron
yes and we have forms and we create and
we'll try and we need to come together
as well it has it already happened
in the golden voltron is real now all
right we have the power of voltron we
now but there's aliens that are coming
and we need to
fight these giant alien creatures i just
i just need you to take that sword off
the wall hold it in the air and yell i
have the power
i do have the power you are human i am
here i have the power and you and your
skeletor and i will fail you what do you
say by the power of grayskull
by the power of grayskull i have no
power you're going back into ancient
history
based on your birth year i grew up with
that dude that was me
saturday morning i'll be cringer i'll be
your cringer baby that was the cat that
turned into battle cat
he was waiting cringer was the name
cringer dude dude i thought you were
just saying like i'm the cringy guy
it's it's tasteful it's timely oh my god
you're right i'm more orco than let's uh
let's go to super chats
my friends please subscribe that like
button super chat
the little like we have nine thousand
likes it's over nine thousand there it
is uh tap that like button
subscribe to this channel make sure you
go to timcast.com become a member
because we're gonna have a bonus segment
does my head always look that big on the
screen yeah i'm just noticing it in the
morning
you got the biggest headache we actually
have an app where we just like we you
know
no we shrank actually look at this it's
even bigger than it tell me if this is
what i think it is to you guys
this is from china xinhua news it looks
like a picture of tim poole propaganda
no it doesn't look does that look like
tim with his guns it is tim
we can do this i want to pull this out i
don't know like that
yeah yeah i don't have a hat like the
guy yesterday had a punisher shirt on
that's not um that's from several days
before this that's from
the yellow beanie i don't have a yellow
beanie no yellow no you don't have a
you can't look at a guy with a beanie
back at simple so it's basically a
picture of two bureaucrats saying to
freedom and then there's this crazy guy
with a beanie on saying of shooting and
he's got an
ar and a pistol and he's like dancing
around all crazy looking
in a t-shirt like tim where i mean it's
just very wear a t-shirt like i'm
wearing
it i know it's slightly different than
tim you're like a guy wearing a t-shirt
and a beanie is tim i'm like he's like
got the beard of you too
like the short dark beard dude my
millennial
wife keeps trying to claim that i'm the
basis for all these memes i think china
is meme
no they're not i'm not that influential
ian's like you see this meme but it's
your argument
no it isn't you see that meme it's you
i'm like no it isn't it's like these
names aren't me it's the archetype of
the
the the hipster beanie skater no it
isn't and they love it
it's just a crazy looking guy who
happens to be wearing a beanie yo it's
all the above
okay so i'll tell you this now at any
point for any reason if someone's
wearing a beanie temple he's got your
beard
100 no every time i wore a beanie all
winter it was because i was simple
yeah i remember one time jack me and
jack were walking on the street and jack
was wearing a beanie
and i wasn't and someone was like oh
you're a tim pool it's a jack person
you grew a beard dude and then i was
like actually i'm like oh
he was wearing a beanie so i just
assumed oh yeah my millennial wife just
sent me a text she goes wtf is a voltron
yes all right let's read the super chats
hayden says closing on my 40 acres of
raw forest
want to build a small close-knit
community do you guys have any tips for
getting started
all trees and large rocks but has
natural springs and a power line on the
corner of the property
near swimming holes too heck yeah i like
geodesic domes
i hear they're cheap and easy and
structurally sound to build timber
framing dude that's the way
i don't know exactly what you should do
i do know that i've uh uh
i thought it'd be cool if you got
like-minded people to just start
building up towns
so like there's a few towns that have
been dying because the railroads are
shutting down yeah
and internet video is a way to
revitalize these towns by bringing money
back into the community
and then you could basically like i
thought about this
go to a small town that's dying then you
can hire the carpenters you can hire the
janitors you can hire the plumbers you
can hire the workers the shops
all of a sudden now there's money coming
in from advertising into this town which
brings the whole economy back
yeah then you encourage entrepreneurs to
develop technology
software bring those towns back to life
my tip for you is to join the liminal
order buddy we got a whole homesteading
crew we even have a whole collection of
people in eastern tennessee that have
been coming together and
we had a guy we had a guy join the ello
find land in tennessee
find a cattle rancher to get his cattle
find the guys in
ello that come and did a fence raising
and a penning in one day
on his entire property just like the
amish would come raise your barn and
build it all in one day
it's amazing you need community even as
isolated as you are
you still need community talk to joe
norman about localism
he'll get you sorted all right hayden
says i'm also going to be starting a
youtube channel too
and documenting the process of buying
land in the building and setup that's
going to take place
as well as drinking beer the swimming
holes at the end of the day it's going
to be a blast sounds cool dude that last
part will be the most successful bit so
stick with that
anytime trip sucks says jack i'm a
private school
science teacher a while back you advised
me to be a secret agent but there are no
boards
course materials up to the department
the history and english teachers use crt
what do i do
you have to keep going man you have to
keep going and you can't you can't give
up
because you have to find like-minded
people you have to keep spreading the
message and you can't
back down so you got to use your own
curriculum you got to use your own ideas
that's what they did at the beginning
that's what you're going to have to do
now keep teaching the science and stay
strong and if you need a network of
people
hook up with people to support you
behind the scenes
you cannot do it alone another reason
why the liminal order exists
are you in a one-party consent state if
you're not
perhaps they're uh you should definitely
check but maybe you could actually just
film with your phone if they're doing
crt
i'm not going to tell people to do that
because there's there's laws on filming
people things like that your state
look we look i just had this argument
with somebody on twitter today as
i was executive director of charter
school districts i've run schools i've
turned around schools i've built new
schools
we designed our classrooms and told our
teachers
and our students to expect to be
observed at any
time we put big window panes
huge picture windows outside the
classroom so that anybody could observe
they were told to expect anybody walking
in at any time to observe them at any
time
parents administrator local official
prospective parent anybody
anyone who pushes back and says that
education cannot be filmed or broadcast
or recorded
or observed at any time is trying to
manipulate your children
do not stand up for that do not allow it
do not permit it
it's a public good with public kids with
children
all right pacific nationalist says jack
murphy since the first time you're on
tim cast i've improved myself and come
up with this
run five miles and work out every day
build a skill and find a hobby
be a better man not just a man but a
better man be a warrior
amen to that thank you so much for those
kind words i appreciate it's that kind
of stuff that keeps me going
please check my twitter feed for more of
that i do a lot of fat shaming online
a ton but i'll tell you what i do more
of is praising people on the right
track so get on the right track
congratulations to you five miles a day
man that's baller good for you dude
ryu woodware says the guest yesterday
said quote do you really want to have
kids in this environment that is the
exact premise of the movie idiocracy
that's right do you want to have kids in
this environment 100 in fact you should
have as many as you possibly can
i heard about your guests on last night
i don't fit i don't know exactly all the
things that they talked about but the
general gist i got was that they were
not big fans on marriage
no i disagree actually uh oh yeah yeah
one guy said in the bonus segment that
he would give up
all of this dating stuff and being a
high value male if it would bring back
the
the traditional family all you gotta do
the other guy said nah
nah he likes where he's at he earned it
he leveled up yeah he leveled up but
when you're 29 and 30 leveling up is one
thing when you're 40 leveling up is
another when you're 50 leveling up is
yet
another thing they they both agreed that
the destruction of the family is killing
society
100 yeah but you don't have to be a
victim as a man
if you want a family there are women out
there that want a family too
and the number one way to protect
yourself against divorce rape and losing
your assets losing your kids and all
that thing
is to be the best man that you could
possibly be and until you are the best
man
you can possibly be all this other crap
is just whistling bullcrap
it's just excuses become the best man
that you can be
and then let me know what happens to you
in your life all right crimson 7 says
tim you should do a documentary series
on the victims of these riots
chaz to combat the one on gen 6. and
welcome back jack
and have y'all heard anything about the
biden earlobe stuff
well first let me say that's a great
great idea actually i think we'll we'll
we'll start seeing if we can get that
going it would be really fantastic to
produce like 13 videos just find
somebody whose business was destroyed in
one of the riots
yeah and profile them for 10 15 minutes
like what's your life like what happened
tell us your story
oh dude so we do a lot of traveling for
my son's baseball tournaments and my
daughter's regattas and such
and so we go to these small towns and
the first thing rochelle
red hen does she looks up she
investigates what restaurant can we go
to what bars can we go to what
what distillery can we go to it is the
saddest thing that we're seeing now
we're going to all these towns
all across the mid-atlantic and the
south from new york all the way down to
georgia
and every time that we've been like
going to a new city and we're looking up
the top 10 restaurants
we go to five of the top ten all closed
all clothes from covid all just shut
down
couldn't survive couldn't make it
nothing
it's tough man what's this earlobe stuff
i have no idea what the earlobe stuff is
all right well then let's make up a
story though okay
uh joe biden was boxing evander
hollowfield and
bit his ear all right take out the
piercings quiet guitarist advances hey
jack looking for more media to consume
that talks about masculinity and being
masculine
do you have any recommendations
yes a hundred percent you should talk
you should listen to all my content jack
murphy live on youtube
spencer clavin does a great job of
talking about masculinity
uh from his particular perspective if
philosophy as well i'm releasing in
conjunction with michael millerman the
renowned philosopher
a seven part lecture series on
masculinity through philosophy from the
ancients all the way through to current
times
you should check that out that'll be
coming out soon follow my feed i
recommend and retweet people on
masculinity all day
long eric a says like in the new
articles from tim cast but on your kyle
retinous story the people are referred
to as protesters
they did 50 million dollars in damage
protesters don't do 50 million dollars
in damage rioters do
you are correct good sir that's why we
have the corrections at timecast.com
so you can send those in but i agree
whenever i read stories and it's like
protesters i go nope
rioters so the challenge is of course
trying to stay on top of every single
rider and every single framing is not
going to be super easy but i will
absolutely
convey that with our relatively small
team come on guys
if they riot in indian damage they're
rioters and you know
determining that threshold for framing
is not always super easy
if you have 100 people holding hands and
singing and one guy throws a brick is it
a riot
probably not fair to say it's a riot if
10 people throw bricks as a riot
i think at that point it's probably fair
to say it's all right and a riot could
be a type of protest
so that can get confusing too not all
riots are protests but some can be
i'm saying i'm saying they level up
right so if you have 100 people singing
holding hands and singing songs your
protest they're protesting if 10 of them
start throwing bricks and bottles and
explosives
i would not call it a protest anymore
i'd call it a riot because those people
who are there have every option to
either leave or stop those people from
doing it but they don't but what if
they're like protesting a crackdown
authoritarian military crackdown and
they're like
trying to blow up you know authoritarian
machines but they're also protesting the
authoritarians it's a riot so it's both
sure but the prefer the the framing is a
riot
yeah don't leave that the problem is is
that at any one moment in washington dc
during the summer last year there were
all there were peaceful protesters
there were bystanders there were
observers and there were rioters and
they were all in the same place
yeah riot's not a peaceful protest
that's for sure they're writing but
that's why i'm saying like figure out
the framing isn't easy
but um if you have 100 people who are
all wearing you start saying
trump bad and they're holding hands and
singing they're protesting if they lay
down
they're protesting if they block the
street they're protesting if 10 of them
start throwing explosives
all of them are in a riot yes it is a
riot now yes
i'm saying if one guy did it i wouldn't
call it a right i'd say some crazy guy
through something yeah
the protesters in portland had the
option to back away
stop these people you know back away or
stop these people instead
they linked arms and protected them they
linked arms in front of them and said
no we're moms i'm like okay you are
rioters yeah they joined the riot at
that point
absolutely but even if they weren't
linking arms and blocking the cops
standing there singing songs in support
of a diversity of tactics
that includes smashing windows and
throwing explosives you are all in a
riot
that's it diversity of attack i looked
up the earlobe thing
what apparently conspiracy theorists say
that changing earlobes prove biden clone
i'll have to look at them no maybe in
the bonus segment i don't know about
that stuff
a little too much for me that's exciting
red run uh
what would it say remix red rumix says i
sued my employer for wrongdoing
i was not sure i would win but i knew i
was right and would not let them step
all over me they tried to bully
intimidate make me resign i defied them
and
won that is awesome yes congratulations
matt bowler says audio messages are not
better than texting they are easily
translated to text and interpreted by a
machine then flagged for review
okay but does the recipient have to do
that
right i mean i'm saying there's less
chance the recipient's going to
misinterpret
yeah or just giving your recipient like
you got to put three more layers of
difficulty into there it's not a secure
but it's like
more than just a text message mr
freaking
hair splitter over there good grief also
if somebody picks up my phone and looks
at it they're also not going to see what
i had written there either so
red rumix says get sticks on the show
sticks is always welcome
stixxenheimer 965 or whatever
sticks hex in hammer 666 oh there we go
i'm like those are easy numbers to
remember jack
i didn't want you to get banned for
talking about devil's stuff
[Laughter]
it's like the most devily devil name too
sticks is he the one who says every day
today is going to be crazy
no that's comfortably smooth oh it's
scary that's about all right today's
gonna be an insane day
yeah he said james nelson says henry
ford created the five-day
week and livable wage you've bought into
the lie labor movement in u.s was
started by bolsheviks
okay say what no that's a hard
statement that was that there was a lot
of conflict in that sentence i think
henry ford bolsheviks gave time off
that sounds good to me these are all
horrible things like time off damn
communists getting us a weekend
god gave you a weekend dog not
everything about the theory of communism
is necessarily bad
just not practical all right balian says
tim if you ever got the chance to
interview trump would you who would your
co-host be and why would it be jack
murphy
um yes to interviewing trump
yeah but remember you see what dave
rubin had to do like long bleeps we
would be able to do it live
we'd have to do it trump would be like
listen listen the thing that happened
with the
special the whole thing was a joke right
what bleeping trump
yeah no you had to go on as locals to
actually see what trump said
uh oh no kidding youtube would you
actually talk to trump i
thought he did yeah oh you know what i
just saw that and assumed it was
fake oh oh interesting it was on the
phone right oh really
yeah oh i thought it was just a whole
joke a whole just bit
that he just put put trump up and like
ask the question and then just use sound
bites or whatever
sorry dave hey nice scoop bro oh maybe
i'm wrong but i thought deep did you do
trump and he had to bleep out
on the screen i have no idea i didn't
even go on
sorry dave yeah go on locals that's why
when bannon was here
you know there was a really funny point
where he started talking about a certain
thing
and then i was like let's just hold and
he was like don't worry i'm not going to
say the magic words
and i'm like i don't know if that
matters to youtube there's like you're
getting a little close to the sun buddy
they're gonna hit that band button
but the bonus segment with bannon oh
wait icarus something with an
eye word flying too close to the sun
when when when
the bonus segment with steve bannon yeah
i bet that that was awesome first
thing i asked is what youtube will ban
everyone for and we just went right into
it so i'm not gonna repeat we're gonna
read more super chats just so you guys
know go to timcast.com
become a member icarus can cure you'll
find the you find the
uh no that's not true go to a doctor
that's right
you you literally can't say that yeah
you can't say that it's greek mythology
it doesn't matter you can't say that
no joke yeah we could get no
non-sequiturs
there's no joking about this dude
they've taken you down like super
superman can do it yes that's just
effective yes
yes yes yes yes yes they took down
crowder for citing cdc
guidelines so it's like we've had people
on the show where i'm like hey
like no you can't like make jokes about
this stuff like okay and they do
anyway and it's like these people seem
to think that youtube
is not sitting there with their finger
over the band button saying i want to
effing destroy these people
i thought we were flying under the radar
but we're not no
you idiot you have to encourage
everybody to go see their own doctor and
ask them for advice 100 and you're not
allowed to joke about it
no joking nope nothing yup youtube is
straight up like
gonna that's it that's it so you know
but when it comes it comes that's why
we're advocating for timcast.com that's
why we have these conversations exist on
platforms that we can have them exist on
and they're getting more and more views
all right rocky range says tim george
washington who also lived in virginia
freed his slaves on his deathbed
after he freed his slaves virginia
passes a new law banning the freeing of
slaves in one's will
thomas jefferson didn't free his slaves
because it was illegal all right well
there you go
sense-making apparatus billy bob
baba ganoush says luke is not slavic to
be politically correct
thing to to be politically to be
politically correct
thing to say is he's slavics with an ex
i couldn't believe it when biden
actually
like audibly said latinx
latinx or whatever he said he actually
actually said the word out loud that
people have only written
goofy foot says jack murphy makes chuck
norris look like a bearded woman
i'll take that as a compliment i think
great yeah yeah that's big okay good
sorry chuck all right
canadian canadian a says hey tim i just
wanted to shout out shad from
shadowversity and game nights
he's an author and youtuber i'm just a
fan but he's doing a great job creating
culture
he's conservative but that's secondary
check it out is he the guy who has like
swords and stuff
i don't know never heard this guy yeah
maybe maybe maybe i've seen him
all right let's see we gotta scroll down
it's gonna do a youtube superchats do a
big jump on me
because they just load instantly super
jump
cutoriously wise says about the draft of
the declaration
during those uh times a potential jail
sentence has to work on a ship
or in the american colonies i think this
is what was referred to
since the crown i.e the king through the
court that is sentenced to the prisoner
uh
i don't know most like i read a bunch
about it and they said that he was
referring to slavery not referring to
um jail sentences he was saying that he
like
like violated human nature or something
like that like
people who have never offended him or
something like that whatever
all right let's see darth vader says
cancer free as of today
tough two years but anyways just wanted
to say what's up and keep up the good
work guys jack i'm a huge fan man
thank you and congratulations to you man
way to fight through that yeah
absolutely
all right oh i can't read that one
mr obvious says we are getting banned
and demonetized we are being snuffed out
just slowly
that's right it's called pressure the
goal is not to ban people outright
because they know that creates ripples
and waves
the goal is to push down slowly until
they're underground
every time someone looks they see you an
inch lower but they're like look the
same to me
it's fine the era of re-monetization is
upon us they want it to seem
like you're just failing you know people
just don't like your videos anymore
the challenges that's why i always say
share this show
share these clips share this show share
the podcast subscribe to it
because they will try to suppress it but
if you are sharing it with your friends
and family
they can't and they'll keep trying but
the people are pushing back
i heard one of the shows we did last
week was about
i think it was about facebook and um the
title said facebook something something
and someone shared it on facebook and
immediately got their account suspended
probably just because of the name of the
video
facebook refused to give us partner
program access
on any of our accounts they said we
didn't create it wasn't original content
and we were like it's their show we have
a show it's a podcast it's actually a
top
itunes podcast and they were like no not
original bye-bye
got an email back i was like we're sorry
we can't help you it's just we don't
have the apparat like there's no
structure at facebook for actually
dealing with this
you'll have to go through the automated
system they were basically saying the
clips we were uploading
which only appear on facebook in that
format were unoriginal
is that because even though it's like
your face speaking words out of your
brain yep
unoriginal yep i wonder if we do it as
ads if they'll
they'll do it then no what they're
claiming is that we're taking someone
else's show and putting it up
not that it's repeating the same show
that you own no they're saying we're
taking someone else's it would be like
if i
just upload to the simpsons right right
right right yeah i'm live
it's bs i don't even go on facebook at
all anymore i barely touch it at all
only for messaging
even then i'm like why am i using
facebook messaging delete that dude
yeah that's tracked and although i have
like saved messages from 2010
that i sent that are still at access
sometimes
can't be that important kevin kelly says
rip he-man the new netflix he-man show
makes he-man the bad guy
and gives tila a new girl power haircut
and makes her the main character
i mean is there not a better character
name for the new he-man than
she man oh it would have been great
wasn't it she-ra it was shira but the
new character has to be
she-man dude have you seen the
documentary about the creation of he-man
it's one of the best documentaries in
the world it's really it's incredible
yeah about skeletor and he-man yeah the
guy
power of grace goal and all that i'm
gonna have a hard time recalling
anything oh check it out check it out
checking it out
james nelson says he-man needed a magic
sword to have power thanks to kevin
smith's wokey men
we now know tila had the power the whole
time and just needed him out of the way
to realize it
of course kevin smith is involved is
that for real
oh he's like i never had the power in
the first place it was always you
somehow giving it to me or something is
that what clerks do you remember
watching that in black and white
would you have predicted that those guys
would go woke no i would have thought he
would have done more lsd
yes i think so really from watching
clerks
these look man people just want
things very few people have principles
yeah dude i want to talk about
this he-man that's why it's like dude
the last people you can accuse of being
grifters are people who are
like i'll tell you this you want to
criticize conservative inc
okay maybe i understand that they make
money you want to consider
uh like dave rubin like he's grifting
i'm like
he could have just stayed with the young
turks and continued to do the mainstream
show why would he choose to be in the
out group
why would he choose to put himself at
risk he succeeded in spite of these
things big risks
i continuously put myself in the out
group of the out group and still people
call me grifter
wow there's no escaping there's no i
could just make a tattoo
like i could do for like so what people
need to understand about success it's
like
do they think that people who are
willing to work 100 plus hours a week or
whatever
are only succeeding because they've
chosen to talk politics
if i was going to work this hard and
really want to make money why wouldn't i
just say whatever amazon
wanted me to say right they're the ones
with the money right who am i supposed
to make money
you specifically are playing on like
elite advanced double extra plus
expert level when you really could just
do it much easier
all you have to do is sell stuff that
just makes you like
get get laid more get paid more you just
focus on that that's how you make money
in the men's space that's for sure
charles balzian says great insight ian
the young turks are awful
also to biden's credit he acknowledged
the armenian genocide
but still sends azerbaijan rockets to
continue genocide
jeez hey well i don't think they're
awful i didn't say that
um but i think that there have been a
lot of awful things
surrounding them lately i think chank is
like losing his mind after the the
hillary clinton email scandal
it's not that it's that these people on
the left who were like i believe in
these things the nsa is bad the fbi is
bad
all of a sudden now we're confronted
with a mainstream establishment left
saying say the opposite of everything
you just said or we'll throw you out
yeah
and so now their brains just right when
i see it in check because he's on tv
so much talking as you can see like his
own like he's twisted and it's not his
fault but he's been twisted by the media
it's simple it's like there's a reason
why people like ruben jimmy dore
leave there's a reason why people like
glenn greenwald are accused of changing
he accuses me of changing it's like bro
we've all been in the same place but
we're not tied to corporate sponsors and
investors
i wonder if what really happened is
these people left were able to speak
their minds and be
free and as the world changed around
them they maintained their principles
and they started calling out the
problems
but jank is is trapped under the boot of
a corporation with investors with
demands
and so he's sitting there like slowly
drifting away like i have to say these
crazy things
and think about how angry you would be
imagine this jack if
imagine if someone came to you and said
literally everything you've done
everything you've built will be stripped
and taken away from you
well your harm will come to your family
you have to say what we want you to say
so depending on you know you're standing
there like feeling the intense pressure
of being forced to say something you
know is not true jank isn't strong
enough to say no to it
well since i've already been in that
exact situation before and elected to
say
exactly what i thought was on my mind
let the chips fall where they may
i can't relate to chenk being a little
[ __ ] in that regard yeah cause they'll
they'll say say these and then you'll be
like i don't want to do it i don't and
then finally one day give in
and then the next day they're gonna be
like okay now do it again right and it's
like what this is my life this is what
my life it's the same principle behind
not apologizing for that stuff too
what's this corporation the parent
corporation of young turks do they are
they owned
well i think they have investors they
have like big powerful investors and
things like that
you know when you said that about him
being boxed in do you remember in the
end of
which superman i can't remember where
like the three evil
the second one sent to the phantom realm
they all get like boxed into like the
little crystal thing and it like
just and they're like yeah it just
scatters off into space that's what's
happening to chanck right now
but he's like he's losing it you know
what i mean he's watching
he can't say any of these things because
he's a tribalist not he's not principled
so there are people with principles like
jimmy dore who will be like here's what
i believe
and then when the left goes nuts or the
democrats go nuts he'll be like screw
that
they're people like glenn greenwald who
are principled now my criticism of glenn
greene in the past is that he's
activisty and he is more political than
you know like in 10 years ago i said
this guy is he's coming out he's
publishing these things but he's always
been an opinion guy
that's fine but he's principled so when
the democrats go nuts he calls him out
when the fbi goes nuts
nsa he's always criticized these groups
how even when his own
publication lost its way he was like i'm
out yeah
exactly because they're like you cannot
force me but what happens when you're
the head of a major company with
everyone staring at you saying
we believe this believe it or else well
i mean isn't that exactly what happened
to
zeiss to glenn oh he had intercepted and
glenn walked away and he walked away
so tank be half the man that uh glenn
greenwald is
glad yeah that works glenn lost control
of the company at that point
chanck i think i would imagine still
owns he has lost control of his own
mouth
yeah this is this is unconfirmed right
no one knows that he's being coerced to
say things
i'm saying in my opinion the fact that
he is toeing the line
for the establishment while pretending
to be a progressive seems so shows that
he is
trapped in a box people on the left why
is it so hard to get many people to
appear on this show
or the grifters will always try i would
say that too like there are legitimate
left personalities who are like i won't
go on the show because
i will get attacked for there's no
upside then you get the grifters who are
like have you in the show and they have
like
really low view counts and they're
really desperate for attention and i'm
like bro
you're you're grifting i get it when i'm
not going to give you air time
and we want to have this legitimate
person on but they're scared they'll get
canceled
conservatives are like i demand you have
me on the show
when are you going to have me on the
show i want to be on the show it's true
it's like that you you go
you go to a trump rally is that right
you go to trump rally walk up with a
camera to microphone to a trump
supporter
and be like hey you want to answer some
questions they're like sure go to a
democrat rally
no no don't i can't advise that i get
sued if someone gets hurt i can't
believe
people people call you up and they're
like i demand to be on the temple
irl they don't demand that they're like
yeah when are you gonna have me where
are we on like it's a given
what i mean is conservatives unless
there's an issue of like they're busy
we'll be like i'd love to do an
interview people on the left are like
why
no i can't do it kg that's it
anyway my friends if you haven't already
you got to smash that like button smash
it go to teamcast.com become a member
because we're going to have a bonus
segment coming up
about 11. we're going to talk about
those things that youtube will ban us
for
and uh yeah you can follow this show
on facebook and instagram at tim cast
irl help
share our videos so that we can leverage
those networks to get people to go to
the website also we've been on tick tock
we've been blowing up on taking that's
doing really well yeah like like huge
like videos getting hundreds of
thousands of views different
demographics it's pretty cool younger
people apparently which is good news
gotta reach those young people who's
doing your tick tock clips
we gotta we got a guy what do you mean i
need the same i
need the same yes i saw the clips on
instagram now i'm like all right there
we go hook it up i hit a follow on that
i got to say the dude that's doing the
clips you're doing a really good job
talented yes very talented so uh but
we're getting we're getting access to
those young people and apparently um
middle-aged women are on tick-tock
so so hey that's good so middle-aged
white women are like my main demographic
those are my girls man so uh but don't
forget you can follow me at tim cast
you can uh subscribe to this channel
share with your friends jack you want to
shout out
i do uh my name is jack murphy i have
all kinds of things i have the jack
murphy live show it's on youtube i'm
jack murphy live on every social
everywhere please follow me on twitter
on instagram
come down sign up for the liminal order
if you are a man between the ages of 20
and 60 or a little bit on either side
you believe in masculinity brotherhood
and sovereignty and you want an answer
to all these problems that we're talking
about and a team to support you
liminal order come down check us out we
take 50 new guys a month oh that's
awesome
well thanks for coming jack my pleasure
it's so good to be back i can't believe
i missed as much time as i did it's nice
we're back on the regular schedule no
more summer crap no more weird things
we're here
i miss my man uh freedom tunes we got to
get
we didn't even talk about my engagement
we didn't congratulations
yeah i mean we didn't talk about any of
these things what's the when's the big
day big date is gonna be in the fall of
2022 can't wait
fantastic thank you so much shout out
shout out
uh i'm ian crossland hit me idiot
crossland thanks for bringing up he-man
that was awesome
and i'm well out of this he-man stuff
but thank you very much jack for coming
back
my pleasure happy to see you again back
on our old routine yes you guys can
follow me at sourpatchos on twitter as i
attempt to get more followers
and sour patches how far away are we i'm
pretty close i think they have uh
92 and i have about 80. oh
there we go here we go and then we can
mock and ridicule sour patch kids yes
yes and we'll get we'll get a bunch of
bags of them and we'll throw them around
and laugh
i love starbucks i used to eat a lot of
sour patch kids
i used to go to the corner store and it
was once one penny per cypretch kid so
i'd be like i'd hand them a dollar and
they'd give me this bag
insane amount of sour patch kids yeah
anyway go to timcast.com become a member
well the bonus
members only podcast coming up with jack
around 11 11 pm or so thanks for hanging
out and we will see you all there bye
guys
you